so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
yo
what's going on
the lord's day
what's popping oh wow black rolling 357
throw the crest up
welcome to the room thank you for
joining sir how are we doing john m
what's going on john m already got his
acquisition bag on he's telling us to
take two things going down officially we
heard it from john m so if it happened
johnny we're going to give you all the
credit
dj oros in the building what's up
firestar what up
lord meyerhoof
salute what's going on another lord in
the building phase xr pycon fusion see i
said it right game zero was going on
throw the crest up outlaw what's up
what's going on we're going to try to
get you champagne in the building
waiting to hear from yeah man early
podcast yeah 11 a.m that's what we do
for the lord's better need a football
addict say what's up to the people make
sure the level is going on guys
you should be able to hear me fine yeah
yeah cheryl mack what's going on bro
give this to you i saw you up in our
xbox era when i was here yesterday
appreciate the love it's all good and
nah love my hope we're good you're good
we will be rocking 11 a.m eastern
probably all the way up into the new
year so there's a new year kick off we
will switch back to 1 pm eastern but we
got to respect the nfl right now we got
to do that so i'm gonna wait you guys
we got it after this i'm going straight
back to business
yeah so we're gonna see if we can get
jimmy in here king and solve and uh
[Music]
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all haven't messed up and turned
me to an animal and headless be swearing
that real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah i be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
[Music]
could say that i'm very spoiled for them
to be your dog thing very loyal but i
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you ain't gotta say it i'm embarrassed
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
turn me to an animal and haters be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by
[Music]
say it i'm embarrassed for you always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire's flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them reigns you're just a target when
i'm in the range i was the hardest to
start regardless back when you was
messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
i'm better than money because you can
bank on me being accountable i know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable i
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i am
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
[Music]
spoiled for them to be your dog's thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i
[Music]
for you always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
fire this is that yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
[Music]
to be your dog thing very loyal but i
ain't gonna hold you i ain't here to boy
you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed turn me to an animal
and haters be swearing they real but
come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to started regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it um
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boil you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable this
[Music]
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that
again here you hear you man welcome to
the show if you would not mind go ahead
and uh find yourself a spot get
comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do and um you
know we're about to get started i am
well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords podcast right now
as we speak and uh i guess i'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
look y'all have messed up and turned me
to an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
oh
[Music]
attic i wanted to chill with the pack
and be like a young wolf but then they
would mistake me for addict if i can
imagine it's cool to give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny worked a cognito who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that jew king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it in nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then it's doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
all right
here you hear ye and we are live welcome
to the islands podcast llc and also live
on lordsofgaming.net
episode number 225. it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date i'm extremely
excited about our special guest and
we've got death loop impressions
xbox acquisition rumors
and geforce now leaks to discuss so
we're going to get right into it
i want to introduce the lord whose
unique skill set a filmmaker podcaster
and content creator is only matched by
his pure passion for 80 slasher fix and
video game culture
introducing the creating host of the
jimmy champagne and ps ready youtube
channel plus the co-host of the fear
frequency podcast
the lord of cool shirts horror and
halloween
with the most iconic last name minus a g
in the game
live from l.a by way of detroit and
making his debut into the realm of the
lords
my man lord jimmy champagne how we doing
sir
i need to like clip that intro out so i
can just put it before my videos
it's awesome that was great that's like
yeah you even got the no g part
excellent excellent i love it what what
you do is you put it on a tape recorder
and just give it to everyone like
grocery store
otherwise how you've been doing sir it
feels like we haven't seen you that long
ago but we have yeah
it's a couple weeks right yeah a couple
weeks i've been going like ever since
that weekend so i've had something to do
and then this weekend i had a chill
weekend wrapping it up with this i'm
excited this is
absolute pleasure man any titty types of
games such a big gaming man which you've
been playing so i've been playing a lot
of destiny that's like my main game i've
been doing the trial stuff i've been
catching up on the two weeks of the
seasonal challenges that i missed okay
and then um i've started hades on my
switch it's pretty pretty solid it's all
right and then uh i have death loop
going too so bounce bounce between like
three games nice that's what's up hell
yeah look i see you we got it we you got
a link on that destiny i'll keep using
it for a little bit but that's good to
see the cross play cosplay yeah yeah
cross plays in there the haiti's going
for tonight to thank for that
yeah yeah
fortnight you know there's one good
thing four nights shout out shout out to
sweeney
how are we good on our channel
welcome to the realm lord black ronin
three five seven put the crest in the
chat for black ronin ladies and
gentlemen beyond that we are good all
right and uh you already know we got the
well we don't have four one horseman is
coming in hot
hopefully the king will be here soon so
you already know what it is we still got
the three other horsemen trust me
king is not missing this g-force now
leaks
it was original lords of the realm here
at the round table with some semi-time
sensitive intros because jimmy's here we
want to respect his time but my co-host
nicole most my brother from another
mother the difficult game conqueror lord
of his own world and the how of the
young wolf mommy lord addict how are we
doing sir
doing pretty good uh you know i i did
beat death loot for the people in the
chat asking uh
you know we'll get into that here later
you know definitely uh going to be a
good show we got a good guest uh excited
uh for it it's because because his
background so i know we're going to talk
about stuff that we don't normally talk
about that's kind of exciting because
it's not it's not football
[Laughter]
i mean you guys could talk about
football just like mute oh you and
attica brothers now oh he loves that add
me to that
oh
[Laughter]
in a good place right now absolutely but
just with death loop sir
yeah i i
look
i love bravery default too
but i don't like that performance on
that switch like
i've not like
normal most the time i understand why a
game play so bad on the switch but i
don't understand why this game plays so
badly switch like if you look at this
game
you like this can run on a toaster oh
damn but on the switch i guess a toaster
runs better than it does really doing
that wow that's what we're doing
definitely doing that man it's a sequel
to a 3ds game right it kind of that's my
[ __ ]
i get it i get where you're landing
slander
well you know maybe they should have put
a little bit more thought process into
the optimization and they'd be no
slander
so don't just those two
and pretty much just uh you know i
didn't really play destiny man every
time i get on there like the you know
neither everyone's full in the clan or
or you know people be having their
parties locked so i just go back to
another game like i don't even bother
with it yeah but we got a lot of we had
a lot of new people but uh i've been
noticing the raid teams have been
locking them down i have seen that rage
i get there's a lot of people doing
raids for the first time so you know
they want that focused party chat well i
guess nobody coming but it is what it is
we get some raids going on but anyway we
got our most technical gaming lord the
solo game who lives with a single player
selfish experience and also the
sastradamus the lord of clarity and lord
patreon of the iron bank mommy lord
sovereign how are we doing sir i'm doing
fantastic so excited to have jimmy uh
i follow halloween stan i'm just a
halloween stan i love michael myers so
the to have jimmy on we we talked for
like an hour a couple of weeks ago just
about like
horror games and horror movies man so
that that is my bag i love that stuff so
in terms of gaming nothing i i wanted to
get in some death loop so i can have
something to say about it today um i got
in late last night i tried to i
literally sat down for like 15 minutes
and it was over it was done
that was it
yeah old man kicked in and that was that
so no gaming um
i watched something like i we talked uh
before we went live malignant okay uh
you know again i like my horror movies
but this one this one was uh i had to
put myself in a mind space to be able to
enjoy this i don't know why when it
comes to horror movies i'm too busy like
laughing about the stuff that that
doesn't make sense to me to like be
scared about anything
yeah for me i'm not scared anymore i
like to see if they can still scare me
right like i turn the lights down and i
really go all the way and have my
headphones on but uh yeah i'm malignant
the drunken ninja real quick ah we got
the drunken ninja five dollar super chat
happy sunday lords check out unruly
heroes just dropped on game pass it's
ori but with kung fu okay
nice okay
shout out to wilmie's in the builder hit
that like button it summons king david
faster you know what i'm saying he
agrees that malignant is a combo of drop
dead fred deadpool and basketball basket
case yeah basket case yeah just like a
remake of baskets
you're going to like this show we got
because wilby's a big horror guy so
salute will be and unfortunately you
like did not summon the king faster so
we still going to be uh going on
hopefully king will join us but we still
got the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord cognito spreading that runner to
the roman iop not telling what you want
to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to defining duke had a great
episode with the amazing maddie plays
and the mayor himself ben smith pulled
up so it was a full fun episode come
check that out it should be up on 399 in
about 45 minutes so
we're talking about what's going on
there and then if you want to get that
defining duke ultimate we have rocked
out and talked about the whole disney ip
wars between xbox and playstation check
that out and then uh of course the last
word would eat bartus and ty got travis
popped off my man ascended no man pulled
up a lot of fun so if you want to know
about the intricacies of pvp the man
this is a font very cool dude we talked
about the trials debate and all that
good stuff so go check that out but uh
yeah for me it's been our destiny season
of the law has been sneaking that in
there and i've been doing some
origami so um absolutely the
sequel now is out
it's on game pass but i went back to the
first one
just to kind of refresh myself if you're
a fan of tenshu you want all of 102
vibes this is the true ninja stealth
game for you do you want to get og
before we start our song oh yeah oh gee
man man two dollars super chat nick was
so disappointed yes i agree so but again
he hated to say that
he had to chat yeah he's like we gotta
let him go you have a passionate base
here listen i i agree like again if you
put yourself in a different mental space
maybe have you know a couple of couple
of drinks yeah you know
there's enjoyment to be had there
that's nothing jimmy
are our chats so passionate they will
they will pay to argue with each other
yes and to keep us hostage
it has happened before we got gerald we
got gerald mack two dollar super chat
check out the movie kate on netflix fire
yes i heard it has a lot of kill build
vibes yeah i'll watch one of the
segments okay good all right
you already know so now we got is what
the lords have been playing i want to
focus on lord jimmy champagne his video
game system history his journey in the
film and content creation and of course
what led him to starting the jimmy
champagne youtube ps ready and fear
frequency podcast so lord jimmy let's
start from the very beginning what was
some of the first video game systems you
had and what got you into gaming
okay so
the first system i had i went over to my
cousin's house and i played his ps1 and
i loved it and then they were like oh
jimmy likes video games i was probably
like five yeah
i uh get home and then
like a week later my aunt comes over and
she has like a big bag of stuff i'm like
what's that what is this she was like
yeah you liked our ps1 so here's all our
super nintendo and all of our games for
it that we don't use anymore and i was
like okay oh [ __ ] this is cool i got
like um
super mario world donkey kong country
link to the past like every good super
nintendo game they had it so i had that
until uh the original xbox came out so i
had a super nintendo okay i had a
original game boy and then the original
xbox came out i got that moved up to the
gameboy sp
then uh
from there got the ds okay and then from
xbox went to 360. went to ps3
then all the way up so yeah so let me
back up a second because you said
something interesting obviously your
first experience was the ps1 which i
love i love the playstation one so like
was it a situation where it's like even
though they gave it a nintendo were you
like but this ain't the playstation that
i like
like did you have that moment yeah
i thought at that point all games were
like what was what i was playing on
playstation like that was my first
memory of seeing it at all and once i
got on it once i had it all plugged in i
was like oh it's flat like this this is
weird but uh
i just got super lucky the first game i
played with super mario world and i was
like oh this is better like i really
like this yeah and i played all the way
through it um and then donkey kong
country so those are the two
back-to-back like epic games that i
played
and i loved it i sat there i used to
carry it around with me like i'd go hang
on my grandpa's house on like the
weekend i'd put the super nintendo in
the bag i'd bring it with me and that
console was so durable and the games
were so durable you could just like
throw them around it was like very
portable for what it was and it's small
too like i don't
like compared to the ps1 original it's
like pretty small so
yeah i i never got a ps1 after like i
played it at their house i played crash
i was like crash is dope and we got
pretty far in it and then i just never
got it until way later on the vita and
stuff and the ps3 you know playing ps1
games you know what's funny um
somehow my mom got a hold of our uh
the video we did with the questions yeah
and she's like she's like aj i bought
you an nes and a super nintendo i was
like no you didn't
she's like how are you gonna tell me
what i did and did not buy for you i was
like i know if i i think i would
remember something like that and you did
not do that i was like i think you're
getting these consoles mixed up that's
what's going on here it makes an impact
no doubt the king has arrived see your
levels is good sir sorry for my
tardiness individuals
i do apologize it was a ruckus evening
you guys can see the mexican food and
the tequila has taken a toll upon the
king this early rising stuff this eleven
eight yeah
yeah this is a detriment to my soul
i do apologize for me being tardy but
again mm-hmm i am here
and uh to our esteemed guests i
apologize for me being tardy wow we
appreciate it that's a great excuse
mexican food is the kill is always yeah
it's literally
my twitter page is kind of crazy it's
kind of crazy you already know so he's
talking that uh that og talk man that
system talk i heard i heard the super
nintendo being super durable
um i heard aj said his mother bought him
consoles that he never got from her
and i actually and i noticed you put my
government name like that okay
and then he's like who's aj
i heard that um
he didn't have a playstation one
okay is it any particular reason why the
playstation 1
wasn't uh received at that point in time
i could i knew i could play it over at
my cousin's house and i liked the super
nintendo so much and i didn't even think
about it i remember like when you're a
kid you always want when you don't have
that was like the one thing where i was
like nah this is good to me it felt
newer than the 3d games because that was
the 3d stuff i was like oh this is this
is a little like the the
input lag was
noticeable to me
it's like a kid and i was like oh no
this is perfect on super nintendo it's
like mario super mario brothers just
like you hit the button he moves instead
people don't realize that 60 uh 60
frames per second was what we we came
from right genesis and the super
nintendo and when we gravitated towards
the playstation and other uh cd base uh
title that was in a 3d realm we went to
30 frames per second
or less
or less
it actually affected us us a
twitch-based guys you know so yeah i
actually feel like i gotta jump in red
shout out to black rodent he said aj is
short for attic johnson
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
back to jimmy say it again so from that
point you pretty much had so many
different systems that you said the the
360. uh did you miss out on the uh the
og xbox that was out that really
interested you at that time oh no so
that was my first like big boy console
original xbox my dad like
he's like he's crazy he
he had this big big wine and liquor
store is like the biggest one of the
midwest wow and somehow
he like
he met this guy at a party where they
were playing poker and the guy worked he
was like a sales rep from microsoft oh
and he like put up an xbox with like
every launch game and my dad got it
absolutely got it for like wow nice and
uh oh you met the guy through the store
that's how it comes into play and
so for the christmas that year when it
came out i got the original xbox like
every game there was like 50 games i
want to say that came out with that
concept we had everything like halo mxk
tv like
all these insane games so i got to just
try everything wow immediately
gravitated towards halo that's like
gotta be my most played game ever nice
just played that like day in day out got
halo 2
and then i actually i got i bought halo
3 before i had a 360. so i would like
bring it to my friend's house with one
of those xbox memory cards and i would
use their
console until i could uh mow enough
lawns to afford a you know 360. i bought
a 360 without a hard drive because i
know my parents they cut me off after
the original
a new game console every year so i had
to buy that one myself and you know what
it made it like way more memorable yeah
especially saved
got a used
no hard drive
360.
and then i was putting this in my memory
yeah
it was crazy i forgot about that not to
cut you jimmy oh
solve remember i forgot the 360 had two
skews right right it had that it had
that that um the arcade skew remember
that okay no it gave you like the little
memory card i had a four gigabyte yeah
yeah and then you had the one with the
20 gig a hard drive
that that you detached from that did
that yeah
yeah what they did was they were trying
to get they was trying to remove the
barrier of entry yes and in doing so
they lowered the price but again if you
brought the hard drive your price just
went back up yeah yeah
you know what's funny like
that kind of mindset than trying to get
that lower lower barrier is probably
like the originated as that happened
like for stuff like game pass and all
access program like that mindset of
trying to get into as many people's
house as possible like all right what
else can we do
i think that was more the mindset of the
s the series s right when when they did
do it and i mean it wasn't different
from the regular 360s minus the hard
drive you know uh the the smaller memory
bank and back then the hard drive didn't
matter as much because we wasn't
downloading to the point that we are now
exactly
exactly i didn't even
the demos i started downloading like a
year late like a year later i want to
say when the hard drive i got that
finally i think i got like really sick
and then i was like dad it was dying i
needed
did you trade in your 360 and just
remove your hard drive from them like
nope
lasted like a year and a day like the
day after it was a red ring ring
red ring i was like oh my god oh
so i got a ps3 i got okay okay
oh he was rich
no i i
saved up money dude like i i was
meticulous about
every gift i got i was like doing math i
had a little notebook how much i needed
with tax like if i trade in these games
i don't play like they'll take this much
off i used to watch gamestop every week
to add because every few months they
would do one where you'd get double
trading credit for yeah yeah yeah
i would trade in i would go to garage
sales too and i would buy like old old
consoles that were still being traded in
i was like really wise you was hustling
baby
it was like this okay my parents were
like nope they're like uh sorry well
we're not we're not buying a video game
so before we just cut you again before
you're going through this process saying
that for the ps3 so that what what was
the era where dad was like okay you're
cut off this is the last system yeah
right after the gps wow
yeah he said the 3ds he was cut off so
ingenuity is the mother of invention
yeah
you know what i got to cut grass i got
to look at the timeline
on gamestop i got to make sure that i
could get in there when they're having
double sail time yeah i actually feel
you i respect your hustle sorry because
dude i remember right after i got the ds
my dad and i we my grandma would go to
florida every christmas so we had to
drive her car down for her and we're
driving the car he grabbed grabs a
newspaper while reading lunch and he was
like hey check this out and he shows me
the psp and i was like
oh no i made the wrong choice
i was so devastated because it looks so
psp look cool wait for it yeah yeah
pretty much i just remember it and then
i just got super lucky one year my
grandparents were feeling really
generous they got it for me for
christmas that year that's like the
biggest gift i've ever gotten from them
and i was like holy crap this is this is
cool so psp i really really like more
than the ds but yeah i saved it for the
ps3 i got um uncharted uncharted 2
little big planet 2 resistance to
i think that's that was like the first
game because there were so many did you
get the form and grill um playstation
yeah it was all scratched up yeah same
deal
yep spiderman
i loved i actually loved that thing
though like it ran so well and then
right back in the generation that blue
ray laser broke which was fine
i don't know that that was um
commonplace with that um you would get
that that yellow line yeah and then you
take it in and you would you would fix
the blu-ray uh laser
it didn't cost much of course probably
like 50 to 75 dollars yeah get it done
but if you have the original uh
playstation 3
that thing is worth money because
it actually played the playstation 2
games yeah did it play playstation one
games i don't remember good question i
don't know if you could put the disc in
no it did it did it right okay that was
that was the first i never tried it they
they did they
need to true back to pat yeah and then
they removed it it was literally a ps1
and a ps2 built into the piste exactly
on on the motherboard and it was a great
if that that's when they was given
really fan service back
and you know justified the price it was
6.99
justified the price that you was able to
take your catalog with you yes so i i
really respected that and you know i did
get a second job for it but
you know how much they go for on ebay
now yes i do
it was that the back compat for ps3 was
so
big it's so critical it was like a
controversial thing when it was removed
in the subsequent revisions at some
point right yeah
it wasn't remember i remember i got a i
got a
settlement for the linux thing
oh yeah oh you got your celebrities
out of this
shout out to song for bringing it up i i
know yo i got that message too sounds
like yeah i'm sad at the petition
we didn't get that much bread back from
somebody's like 20 like 20.
i got 12 yeah yeah yeah
shout out to all of messy lords who
fronted like linux was so important to
them just so they could settle how
difficult
to get twenty dollars because when i
stayed in the mail i was having good at
it i was like who are you to tell them
what they should or should not be upset
with
i'm sure there was plenty of people
upset they couldn't put
yeah i forgot linux ps3 was a very
unique system it had back compat and it
did have linux as a os to sell what
wasn't that um uh ken katarugi's last
console that he made for the playstation
yeah that was the last one because the
playstation 4
uh we know uh was mark cernan yeah
that's the morning all right okay
so that was his last great console
um and that's when they went with the
cell processor right and they had the
you know people had to wrap their heads
around the cellphone i think that was a
great uh thought process going into that
because
that cell processor allowed us to get
the last of us
oh yeah it allowed us to get uh um metal
gear uh you know certain titles that
yeah the 360 could not do yeah because
it was programmed in a certain manner
for it and i think he was a way ahead of
his his time
not to cut your kick they finished
strong strong
they started to really mature with the
tools but in the beginning it was rough
because a lot of the
the um generator i mean the
multi-platform games yeah generally ran
better on 360 at that the reason why it
ran better on the 360 because remember
the 360 was uh
uh stuff power pixels power pc yeah
you know these these things was it was a
hog much it was a small pc you know put
together and uh people that uh developed
in that language yeah it was easier to
park those games over but playstation
specific games
phenomenal oh yeah when they had their
oh yeah totally for sure so i want to
get back to jimmy with him right you
mentioned that psp
you know and how you thought maybe you
might have made a mistake
talk to us about that i definitely
there was not a lot of good ds games at
the beginning you had super f64 which
you can only play so long right you eat
it you finish it you get all the stars
you're done yeah and then i don't even
remember i think the next game that i
really wanted was like spider-man 2 or
something like it wasn't a good game
and then i got the psp and everything
changed i got yes underground two
they had like oh my god death junior
uh
liberation i played that game so much
uh there's so yeah there's an incredible
amount of games
the ones i love the most for psp is when
they brought final fantasy tactics
yeah i had that that was so good we got
to give psp as flowers it doesn't get
enough credit i'm glad you brought it up
because um king i remember like
large titles i'm going to say ridge
racer was there they had like racer
wipeout wipeout was amazing soundtrack
oh my god wipeout was amazing yeah and
um i remember a a very impressive tekken
5 port i believe yes second five namco
pulled it off on psp we didn't even know
how they did it we were like this is
sorcery what they were able to do yeah
and then midnight club three that was on
there yeah yeah that game had like
literal five-minute loading times yeah
it was worth it it was worth it
jimmy remember the umd's
i'm looking at the list now there's
there was a lot along apriscape april
atv
but the ones that i didn't think were
launched games luminous um metal gear
acid
but i don't i know you had it because
every baseball game you had wow yeah we
had to get ps2 twisted metal head on
also great and then untold legends was
like secretly really fun my brother and
i said that a lot slowed the psp giving
his roses so there you got that so you
just continued on
i was going to say yeah i see some
kidding questions
like i noticed some there's some
gaps a little bit so
32-bit error you kind of stay you stay
probably stationed all that stuff i get
that but yeah did you ever venture out
into all those what are we considered
like these consoles maybe turbo graphics
maybe 3do or i did later oh okay because
of uh angry video game nerd i got like
that's my favorite youtuber that dude's
like why
i do youtube
i'm pretty sure so i discovered all that
stuff through him i bought an nes on
ebay i remember i was at like uh
senior year homecoming high school i
bought one on ebay and i was like so
stoked and my girlfriend that was like
what are you what are you talking about
it's like i just got an nds i was so
excited i had like power gloves with it
i tried all that out oh my god
i still have that and yes it came with
the box and everything and i got it for
35 dollars so really
yeah wow a bunch of games and then uh
yeah i would go back and play all that
stuff on emulators and everything like
that just so i could kind of experience
it i did yeah my buddy had a genesis
i i never drive with it just because of
the games he had he had weird stuff
like game connections yeah
i think yeah i think because i i do you
know i love tv shows and movies and i
think that's why like the click
like um telltale and stuff that they did
i think that's the reason those games
always gravitated towards me because it
like merged two things i love together
you know what i'm saying i feel you bro
i think what it is too attic is that
like you see you're like an rp like the
recipient of the good movie tired but
like for us back in the day and like
travel like you got to stay at it
whenever a movie game came out it was
like historically bad kind of like
demolition man
um
i'm jealous because attic gets to
experience the great moviegay time yeah
what could have possibly been good in
that anyway
here we go
emotional age old shaymin
somehow you're gonna expect me to
believe you could put a 32-bit area make
it a decent movie game oh here we go let
me tell you this i'm gonna tell you this
you guys were just saying they were
their cd player took it to the next
level
and everybody aspired to do exactly what
turbo graphics did when we had e's uh
book one and two
that's the first time i heard like live
voice acting oh yeah and i was looking
at the game like oh my god this is
incredible orchestral sound
lords of thunder these these games
changed uh how games were brought to us
because the cd base that that sound was
incredible it's incredible yeah so you
know sega went that avenue and i think
they failed miserably but oh yeah yeah
that's why i'd be like
laughing on twitter when people like
when i was talking about that ten dollar
upgrade that playstation five tanks yeah
and and the first argument everyone did
you go with the dvd and and demand and
upgrade to a blu-ray it's like that's a
hardware to a hardware that makes no
sense
absolutely you know yeah
it's a bad argument against you yeah
they're not that great
yeah well yeah man so again you got that
and then the last question i had before
we move on with um any video love
because i know that's big
so yeah media camp
vita is how i got into the whole writing
thing i loved the video i had that
day one i went and gamestop i got pretty
much all the launch titles i want to say
which there were a lot of questions okay
you said day one did you camp out no
because i was it was in holland michigan
dude like okay you didn't have to no one
was playing games
he just walked in nice and easy
i would go to this game stop like
probably once once a week just to see
what's up and i was always the only
person in there and it was like a really
nice game stop too it's the same thing
here like when i tell them like oh are
you going to go get the are you going to
reserve the the series x i'm like yo
they ain't nobody here buying games like
that they only caught like because the
series x and ps5 were already didn't
have a whole lot of stock i kind of
struggled getting that
but i still was able to get a series x i
don't i had to buy a ps5 used because i
could not find one new at all but the
only one that i really have to struggle
getting is switch stuff like nintendo
stuff because oh okay
because it seems like that's a little
bit more widespread like i was able to
get the day one switch
but that's about as far as that would go
like because most of the time there was
a good time for like six months to nine
months the switch was constantly sold
sold out that makes sense so yeah you
say it jimmy you so you dice game stop
you go go in there for the vita hot yeah
so i i just played resident evil
on the 3ds i loved it revelations and
i traded in that game in the boat
attachment for it to give you the extra
thumb stick yeah
some of the gazelles so i really didn't
have to pay that much for the meetup i
was obsessed with that thing i was like
doing updates on this website with uh
you i think you guys had her on miranda
sanchez we had a website yeah and so we
like came up together there
we were
my first game review ever was um
guacamelee on the vita
of that game pretty good game yeah when
the ps1 stuff came to the veto that's
why i started playing it like symphony
of the night and racing two and three
like those are really
really good games to put on the vita
because they ran like pretty well yeah
good controls uh
the oled screen looked great so yeah
vita is awesome i i love that console i
was playing it all the way i got the
revision i played it all the way to the
end like when they stopped
really releasing big games i think the
last game i played on it was that cappy
game super time force ultra yeah it came
out on ps plus
it actually sucks the fact that the vita
didn't i know do what i expected it to
do really i still have all my video
games and
i think what it was the reason that that
that didn't succeed is was because like
playstation was kind of half in half out
with it like yeah they kind of wanted
the same studios to make infamous make
like another infamous for that game
instead of making games they're portable
fun portables and games that are
designed to be portable yeah shout out
to colin because we also found out
that from uh from a security standpoint
once they were kind of breached even
though they had like they had the
proprietary memory card stuff but you
know
we knew there were methods to to get the
games yeah yeah
so um there were methods and um i think
once the the the kind of the back door
was open on that you know it kind of the
floodgates are on and from my from my
understanding i believe you did some
research on it you know that was one of
the factors as to why they started to
close up shop early yeah
it lasted it lasted longer than the psp
because the psp got broken really really
yeah um because of the cd right and
once they happened to the vita that's
the thing like
it was a great console for people to get
to mod just like the psp was but at that
point playstation's like all right
there's no point we're going to lose
money on this and right right but i want
to give it back to jimmy real quick um
in reference that like some veda is
remember how they had like that remember
they had the circles in the um the os
right so like remember they had like
this thing where it was like something
like vida near or something where you
could just
see who's closing
that word i like looked up to you like
snapchat
yeah yeah it was like the worst from
with the thing on 3ds was really good
i had i had somebody that was in my
building and i would always
i forgot which game it was but we will
always be trading information back and
forth because he was close
correct me if i'm wrong didn't this near
thing had some added functionality with
certain games where you could either
interact or trade like you said trade an
item yeah or like certain games
supported this near thing in my bucket
i'm trying to remember it i think in
theory i never got to use it because no
one i knew had a vita i only had one
person in my building that was there and
i was like oh he always there hello
i remember
i got uh when i got a vita because i had
two of them and i remember i bought one
and it was like
i was like a 10th or 11th grade
something like that and i remember
playing final fantasy tactics like all
night and then like saying i was sick so
i had to go to school the next day
yes
it was it was ridiculous like that that
was such a like a handheld that they
like on paper should have destroyed it
it should have been yeah it was yeah but
it's just nintendo supported
that their console and sony didn't so
continue
some more standouts i remember hotline
miami coming to vito was so good i loved
that killzone mercenary was really good
i loved that game that was one of the
first few copies i got from sony which
felt so cool i was like
in the game from the big boys
yeah i played that a lot
i i played so many indie games on there
like ali ali i remember that was like oh
i love olly
i like platinum bit it was
like you couldn't plant him it just had
a lot of trophies but no platinum but i
still did it 100 percent of it
uh gravity rush i thought was okay but
it was an easy flat so i did that
there's a ton of games a ton of games
and last night borderlands 2 on there
yeah they did yeah they're probably
wondering at rapperty ran the greatest i
definitely want to salute them because
to this day
vita was still ahead of its time like it
had the apps one thing i loved about it
is the synergy between that and the and
the ps3 and the fact that your trophies
all that had its list but remember jimmy
they had
the voice chat on
switch that does not have
and you was able so like i could be in a
party chat with somebody on playstation
or whatever
playing different games so basically it
was cross platform cross at party chat
which to this day a certain leading
console
it's so weird yeah you still had it in
like two months right like the sad thing
is
it had bluetooth back then yeah
it's just like wow how did it take so
many years and apparently the the
technology on the switch it's always
been there because that's how they see
some of the stuff they have so it's just
like if you could have unlocked
bluetooth from the start why'd it take
you four years so i i was i actually was
looking this up and some of the answers
that i found was the fact that they had
plans you know bluetooth it takes up it
takes up
memory whatever it takes up so you can't
you can't have multiple things connected
because then there's all these lag
issues or whatnot so i guess they had
plans for other features that were more
important to them and during the course
of these four years they've either you
know fallen off the table whatever they
don't want them or whatever so now they
feel like they can you know whatever
resources they had planned for other
features that aren't coming to fruition
they're just like let's just turn on the
bluetooth so that's that's it that's it
that's it oh my god i can't but and
there's lag i tried it
oh yeah
oh it's not even bright it doesn't work
right you wait this long it doesn't even
work it don't even work right
i shot it with air pods and uh
sony the sony wx1000s
neither it's just there's really really
lagging wow
shout out to nintendo for just me you
know what doesn't i bought the eight-bit
dough attachment way back like two years
ago at this point oh yeah okay no lag no
no
no i never got one of those i keep like
a pair of classic earbuds just rolled up
in my switch case
you know what you know what i do yeah i
don't i don't play it
i'm getting there
when the portability was like a factor
right where it was novel and everything
you can kind of convince yourself that
it was okay playing games at 28 frames
per second and stuff but it's it yeah as
time goes on i'm like the vita ran indie
game is better than the switch yeah it
looks better on it too because the
screen was smaller
everything that just which gets praised
for the veto was doing
honestly better yeah i don't understand
it and they had oled before yeah switch
they had they had trophies
real consoles
i played all of my my indie stuff on
switch but as soon as that steam deck
hits oh yeah yeah i'm preemptively
buying games on pc now yeah yeah yeah so
your steam live yeah yeah i mean
let's just be real the reason the switch
took off the way it was is because they
built that kind of following for for
decades so yeah when they finally was
like we're done with consoles we're just
merging the platforms together we're not
doing no more 3ds we're merging both
platforms together people was down
because at that time people was only
buying a 3ds for pokemon people
they really purchased that console
because dudes didn't understand what the
wii u was yeah exactly yeah they
everybody
didn't do well and then obviously they
had a great launch title with breath of
the wild and you know and to their
credit you know for them that was having
power for them you know i'm saying a
little bit more power and stuff oh yes
of course because people gravitated from
the wheat yes they didn't purchase the
wii u because they thought the wii was
like some weird extension they thought
it was actually the screen
i don't even i think that was at the
beginning but you know towards that
middle because that generation wasn't
long at all like they were pretty quick
but after like you know a year year and
a half i think people acknowledged that
it was a new system but nintendo was no
longer supporting it because how bad it
did out the gate like you can't really
tell me too many like huge hits that
came on the wii u generation because
they killed they kept those in the
barrel and shot them for the switch
generation yeah
shout out to to nintendo for still
selling wii u's for the regular
wow look man we're going with the game i
know we got a lot to talk about but i
definitely don't want to miss out on
other aspects of jimmy in reference to
you know the filmmaking aspect you know
you're a filmmaker you know what i'm
saying and obviously i want to know like
how did that passion develop and then
why such an affinity for horror why such
an affinity for like the slasher genre
and all that stuff too
dude i i don't know what the affinity is
i watched amc fear fest when i was a kid
every year i used to like count down
when it would start that was what they
do it now where it's a whole month but
that was that started last year again
but every year it gets shorter and i was
so bummed but i saw halloween and
halloween four
okay like when i was really young i was
like this is sweet i love this love
michael myers this is awesome
saw a bunch of the nightmare movies on
tv so i got like the cut down version of
these movies for when i was like a
little kid and they were still scary so
then in high school
angry video game nerd every year does
this thing called monster madness yes
where every day of how uh october he
would do a movie review so
he brought back all these movies because
i was still watching the same one so i
was watching halloween humbling for
halloween five all the way up mm-hmm
season of the witch did you like a
season of the video yeah
magazines like fangirl yeah yeah i
really like it yes i was really into the
effects yeah like so that's why i watch
the movies practical effects i like i
like the technical side of it more so i
can go so my question to you right and
going to this do you like animatronics
or
okay so like i'm a huge fan gore
magazine dude and uh when they were at
animal uh animatronics
for those people that don't know um
that's like putting robotics over
prosthetics and stuff like that to
achieve uh uh a more realistic view of
it is a little bit more old school uh
but for purists
we love that kind of stuff because i
think you can go a little bit more gory
with it so um
do you like the switch that they did now
from animatronics too i hate it thank
you so like cgi no that's what you mean
talking about yeah um it sucks you can
tell because even though you you can
look at animatronics and prospects and
like you know it's fake it's it's real
it's technically real like right in the
real world like there's in space people
are interacting with an object whereas
with cgi it's like
you can tell when people are looking
past it you can tell that they're not
really interacting with stuff it ages
really poorly there's so many
uh drawbacks and it makes movies more
expensive so i don't really get
why the big switch happened all that
much i mean there's like stand on movies
that do it really well but those are
like few and far between especially with
poorer where you've got low budgets to
begin with so yeah no definitely really
into prosthetics animatronics stuff like
that i like look for movies that have
that dude there's this one i tell people
about it all the time no one's ever seen
it it came out last summer and it was
like it came out the perfect time when
all the movie theaters closed down yeah
right it was called the wretched and
these guys in michigan made it their dad
did all the effects on the evil dead
movies right so then they
one of them worked at pixar forever and
he put pixar then they made this sweet
like when to go movie that's all filmed
and shot and set in michigan they killed
it the effects are insane but that movie
did great because practical effects made
it like go far and then all the theaters
shut down and it was like the only
drive-in movie so they spent like i
think they spent like an insanely low
amount of money and it was the number
one at the box office for an entire
summer
the most 80s horror movie i've seen in a
while so i was pretty pretty excited
about that absolutely you said the
wretched right yeah direction yeah i'll
check it out because i just watched uh
malignant last night yeah
[Laughter]
and i think that was a culmination of
their work that they did with uh
luigi and um what was that um insidious
yeah insidious yeah yeah contrary to all
of his movies yeah it was really good
stuff no doubt absolutely yeah i love
that aspect i love the the halloween
love and oh yeah yeah i see the buyers
fixed and stuff like that so it's real
cool that you you have that aspect so i
wanted to transition you know with
content creation because you kind of in
a unique space because like i said you
have two youtube channels you know
obviously you have right jimmy champagne
channel and more focus on the halloween
stuff and i mean i mean the horror stuff
and then obviously the ps ready channel
the playstation channel so what inspires
you to kind of really get into youtube i
know you kind of hinted alluded one
content creator was was was that it or
what made you make take the leap and say
okay i want to do this now so anger
video game nerd stuff was what made me
like aware of youtube and what made me
want to start doing it though was when i
started writing news for ign
and i don't know just the crew that was
there at the time i didn't like jive
with them and then it was right after
colin and greg left and i was like
man if they're leaving for youtube like
and then i see other people leaving for
youtube i'm like something's going on
like that's going to be the next thing
so i immediately just switched over
started over right after i graduated
college okay i was doing like game
videos i i didn't really like that so
then
i don't know how it happened but
oh when i moved out here right when i
moved out to la okay um i met austin
evans a year into living here and then i
started working for him okay i went to a
youtube workshop and i got hired out of
it i didn't know it was like wow there
was like it was like a secret job
recruiting thing for that like it was uh
it was a youtube workshop hosted by
apple for final cut pro and i took a
sick day to go and i met austin and i
got hired the next day so i quit my job
and i moved on your phone
and then um
that's where austin taught me like
everything i know about youtube taught
me how to like edit right and
that's where i learned all the thumbnail
theory stuff like that all the
the real stuff that helped me like grow
on youtube and then so i started
applying it to my channel which was kind
of just like treading water and i
remember i did this video when they
announced that halloween 2018 was gonna
ignore two onward okay and i was like
here's why that's a good idea basically
like did a whole like breakdown and it
got like 180 000 views so okay and so
that the poster came out for halloween
and i did a five minute video on that
and it did like 20 000 views so i was
like holy crap this is like
i i get to make videos about halloween
my favorite franchise ever this is great
i just kept doing it and then in between
halloween and halloween kills like when
kills started ramping up i was covering
the new child's play remake
from a negative side and i was like oh i
don't like that so i just went back to
halloween
and then uh p.s ready came up
because austin wanted wanted to like
expand this year this was like the year
of expansion our company overclocked
media and then through another company
that austin's a part of like we uh like
all got together and we're like what's
what's a good niche right we looked at
my channel how it's like a niche and we
grew it i grew to like the maximum of
the niche of halloween like what's it
what's a niche that's big we're like
video games like what's the biggest one
that i could talk about regularly that i
know a lot about that like i've been
through pretty much my whole life
starting with the ps3 which is funny and
uh
playstation so then we started up ps
ready and nice
dude i'm telling you right now we we
were like expecting
i don't know like 80 views the first
video we thought was going to be like a
couple years before you know we were
even
rolling on it and
we just got super lucky
got out there really quick youtube
featured it within a month i think i was
playing resident evil 8 where when it
came out i was like this game is awesome
nothing can make this day better that i
like look at the analytics thing it's
like getting this huge spike what's
happening what happened and i look and
it's like we're on the gaming page of
youtube it was like oh my god this is so
cool so it's like a whole full circle
thing like i started youtube with like
watching any video game nerd and like
monster madness wanted to write for ign
wrote for ign didn't like writing for
ign so i was like i'm done writing and
then switched to youtube and that that
was like a reset took a long time to get
to where i'm at now with it but now i
feel like that was the right move all
along
that was smart
i got
i'm looking at your uh your thumbnails
like they are crazy
[Laughter]
yeah they're crazy good jimmy's a beast
man one thing i respect about him is
just like obviously you mentioned the
analytical nature you know and you've
truly helped a lot of people you know
say behind the scenes as far as
achieving obviously you mentioned the
amazing you know austin evans you
consulted for we call him the shadow
broker of last stand
dustin you know what i'm saying it's
absolutely dusty
yeah he's awesome yeah he's really him
so it's like you know how does it feel
like kind of to be relied and respected
upon cause you're also a producer for
austin as well as well so like how does
that feel to be entrusted when people
come to you and consult to to grow their
channels and get advice from you it's
cool it's it feels cool to like know
that i know a lot about something enough
where i'm comfortable talking about it
with like authoritatively um mostly it's
just with friends though so we're
already talking about it to begin with
like we're playing destiny or whatever
like dustin i'll just be like talking
about youtube stuff because he's really
interested in it and he's really smart
he knows a lot about it and most of the
stuff he just already picks up on and
then asks me if he'll be like is this
how this works i'm like yep like every
time so it's cool just like talking to
people about their channels because i
don't know like over the years a lot of
people ask for advice and then you give
it to them and they either don't follow
it or
which which really gets me like if
someone asks for advice
and then i take time out of my day to
like give it and then they don't use
them like why did you ask why it just
frustrates me and then people who like
take your advice and then they get big
off of it or they got hollywood on
youtube
yeah you never hear from me i'm like
what is that like i don't care because
that that's like it would have happened
anyway at that point you know they would
have gotten too big to still talk to
people but i don't know so stuff like
that used to bother me so i wasn't
helping people for a while but then i
met dustin and we were we'd play games
just talk and talk and talk and then i
would just keep meeting people like
through him bringing people into the
chat so it all worked out and then our
mutual friend jake valdino i helped him
have been grinding hard on his personal
channel for like the past year
absolutely and i think it's going good
good dude man i love hearing these
stories that's that's pretty awesome
what i was gonna say too is um obviously
you said we had that conversation about
helping people it's funny when we use
office kicking it and i wanted to talk
about your other podcast which is the
fear frequency podcast yeah shout out to
your amazing co-host george who i
believe was there right at the speaker
yeah he's getting our drinking cigar
wrong you know what i'm saying so salute
to george
so like you know how did that whole
thing start as far as fair frequency and
like like a weekly horror podcast
yeah so we kind of like wound it down
just because
it was i'll explain it so like we
started the podcast because
i was out here in la george is in
michigan we've been best friends since
like sixth grade and we wanted a reason
to like kind of catch up every week
because we play completely different
games he's not a multiplayer guy he's
like a hardcore jrpg guy
not really even really a shooter guys so
we were always playing different stuff
wanted an excuse to talk so we started
up the podcast and it did it like grew
and grew and grew
and it got to the point where
i was i can't put out a crappy product
so i was spending like five six hours a
week editing it
i was like i need this to make money
or i can't like justify it just cuz i
got so much going on right now yeah and
then
i just like notice with podcasts unless
you've got like a real audience like you
guys are public so it's like everyone
knows like a lot of guys watch your
podcast but there's other ones that are
just audio and i noticed that a lot of
them
sell their ads and stuff based on
downloads and downloads don't mean
listens and i was like how i looked at
my phone and i was like how many people
are like subscribed to a podcast
and it's downloading every week and they
haven't listened to it since the first
time they subscribed to him like
probably a lot that's a good point
so it's just kind of like wound down
because we were
uh every week on shutter the streaming
service they do this thing called uh the
last drive-in and
they're they run this show for long
seasons at a time and they do holiday
events so we would get on discord and
what we would stream in our discord chat
and then talk there so it's like oh
we're doing what we started the podcast
to do and it's so much less frustrating
so we kind of voted down a little bit
but it was really fun we were covering a
lot of movies we had a few scoops come
out of it we were interviewing
filmmakers it was pretty fun
yeah once it started making like getting
into making movies more
i it got a lot harder to criticize other
people's work because i was like
i know how much goes into this and we
were watching a lot of indie stuff and
i didn't want to like you know flame
other people's
because you never know like you never
know
you don't know what happened to screw up
one part of the movie yeah big time yeah
love it man love it i'm sorry itself
real quick on back onto the filmmaking
stuff
how how was it making that that
halloween fan film the first time man it
was fun like
uh my buddy cortland who i made it with
this all started because i wanted to
make like a five minute video like a
very short just fun little halloween
clip to put up
on the day that halloween kills was
supposed to come out last year
like here's something to watch and then
it just
snowballed like we were like oh what if
we did this
we kind of wrote this whole script that
wrapped around as like a trick-or-treat
style thing where like he's gonna be
sick and then vinnie from
womp stomp films the guy didn't never
hike in the snow he
has played michael myers in other short
films so he hit us up and he wanted to
play michael so we like got that figured
out and then the smartest thing we did
we shot it in michigan so
everything was essentially free that we
used except for like the cameras and
stuff we had to pay for like that's all
our equipment
um
so what we do is we had a pickup truck
and a generator and like one light on a
big pool and then we would like roll up
to a corn field jump out
like three four hours
that that high school that was an
abandoned high school equipment
we shot there no one said anything
no purpose shout out
the graveyard we just rolled up at like
two in the morning shot shot there all
night we left all those pumpkins there
if you guys i apologize for jimmy when
you came to your loved one's gravesite
and you was being you thought you were
being trolled but yeah
for you guys if you haven't seen it yet
right it's
you look at it and you're like oh this
has such amazing production value
and it is just like they were in the
location like it felt like yes we are in
hatton field like this is it like
it was like it was just so perfect like
the lighting there was even there were
moments did you have a fog machine or
whatever yeah that's oh my god
it's this fog machine i bought at a
garage sale for like 20 bucks
it's like a skull on the front of it but
we took this the skull off and it's like
a it's like a movie quality like big
movie quality that i got for 20 bucks
and it stand in the back of my car for
like four years
hope this works and it worked great it
worked perfect like
quick charges
and the dude the best part is in that
graveyard that shot where we have
michael like slamming the guy my friend
on the tombstone he actually hit him on
the tombstone once
like that bloody mess cracked in half oh
my god
he was like cross-eyed
he was like in the movie he's like i
hope you're okay but we're using that
yeah we're like
practical effects damn it
we were saying uh we would stay up until
like four or five in the morning we're
losing all the dark dark time and then
the next morning we like go to wake him
up and he's like not answering we're
like oh [ __ ] we killed him
and then he just turns over he's like
i'm fine
on this mask
like
i paid like a lot of money to get this
mask
oh wow and then so it's like this is the
trick-or-treat studios one that you buy
for like 60 bucks
the sculpt on it is perfect but the um
the paint is terrible so if you get it
repainted and like the hair redone it's
it is very similar to the one in the
movie so is that getting the the
mechanics jumpsuit weathering that that
was really
that was expensive and then i got these
custom prop knives made for the movie i
got two of them those were really
expensive you think like just this
prop aluminum knife would be cheap but
getting it done right
costs a lot of money so i spent the most
money on that so the
the one that the one that gets broken
off yeah and you know what i'm talking
about the one was that one of those or
with that yeah yeah so we i got two of
them and we saw it in half to make that
effect
that that effect was
honestly really easy like it was very
simple to do it was just like uh like
latex right and then okay
george when george is dead when he's got
his uh like the fire poker in him that's
just latex stuck to him and then we put
like raw meat all over them
and then when the kid gets cut in half
that is the the easiest effect we did
but i think it came out pretty good
that's like a that's like an adult dummy
where we pinned up the arms put it in
the clown costume and then we just
cut the dummy in half and put expanding
foam at the bottom and painted it red
and then
we nailed venice into it
a bunch of fake blood and it's a donald
trump wig
so we got his spirit halloween and then
i love it yeah we just got really crafty
with it
i think all in cortland and i each spent
a thousand bucks which we feel is
a lot less than it looks like it cost so
that was the goal so it was a lot of fun
it was a year ago like this weekend we
did it yeah um in september so we
thought turn around that's what's up man
salute to you man love love the journey
with with film and and i'm assuming
there's more coming and yeah more plans
things cooking up in the films yeah i've
got
covert makes it hard which sucks
obviously
i gotta have a good idea now i want to
kind of do original stuff and i've got
like some ideas for there but ps ready
man is taking up so much of my time
so once that gets to the point where
we're gonna stop grinding then i'll like
okay when we're coasting that then i'll
get back into the filmmaking and stuff
like that but i'm always watching movies
it's kind of honestly as much as i love
doing the podcast it's kind of been
great not doing it because now i don't
feel like i have to be critical yeah and
now i can go back to what i like doing
which is like
what is this movie's goal and did it
achieve it instead of
oh well you know i saw the the cgi was a
little off there
knocking points for that i hate that
yeah brother real quick rock rolling
before we move on all black world says
what movie are they talking about they
want to know how they can get access to
it where they can find it what's going
on oh you just go to uh go to my youtube
channel it's jimmy champagne you can
type it with the g now and it'll come up
and it's right it's the first video it's
pinned right there it's called happy
halloween
uh halloween kills facebook chat yeah so
you get like 13 minutes 13 minutes get
your boy jimmy investor i love the
unique like i said the horror the
filmmaking the gaming ps ready but with
all that we still got to ask you the
question that we ask everybody in the
realm
i need more jimmy champagne's top five
video games or franchises of all time
okay
uncharted we'll put it five just because
there hasn't been a game in a while so
it's not like
fresh but i remember man i loved
uncharted uncharted one and three two i
also really like i think a little i
don't say overrated because it's like
that implies that it's not amazing but i
think people give that one way more
credit than three and i think three is
better and then four is awesome and lost
legacy so the charter series that's five
we'll do metal gear salad because vita
and psp man mellow your salad p uh peace
walker that is the game that's probably
my most played game ever
and then you were talking about how the
vita could connect to the ps4 and ps3 i
was playing i had my ps3 still i had
metal gear hd collection on the ps3 and
i figured out a way to transfer the
saves for peace walker between vita and
ps3 okay so nice pick up on the tv it
was so weird it was like such a weird
process you had to do but i figured it
out it felt really cool about it
and then um so that's too much you're
solid love that
uh resident evil okay gotta go with that
because you know resident evil fours
like first
big horror game love it
um
what do i play a lot oh we'll go with
dishonored i love oh okay okay yeah
design's great i play those games all
the time and then
dude toss-up for number one game ever
it's like really really hard you know
you got like left for dead two you've
got
evil within two i think is like one of
my favorite games ever that game is so
underplayed and underrated i'm looking
at my steam right now
control okay oh man there's so there's
so many games recently that
i'm like this is my favorite game this
is my favorite game uh how may i mean we
can go with okay okay nice okay yeah i
like a lot of violent crazy
murder
absolutely and then halo well you know
my favorite game of all time is we'll go
with uh
uh halo
2 halo 2. halo 2 okay okay absolutely
absolutely treved this game history i
gotta ask you a bonus round question
because you're a unique guest so oh yeah
you don't have to do that we're gonna
miss okay nevermind
no no go go do what you're gonna do i i
there's something about him that we
didn't speak about i don't know if you
purposely did that okay i don't know we
could do what i want to do now and then
you you'll you carry on what yes at
least
so on bonus round you don't have to do
five but at least top three
horror movies of all time
okay halloween for sure
evil dead 2013.
that's like oh man ah it's so good let's
go and then
um i want to pick
now see the third spot's where you get
the biggest pool yeah
ah
i gotta think
i don't wanna do evil dead two because i
already said you will like 2013. okay
um
uh
i gotta pick a halloween ish movie oh
trick-or-treat
yeah oh yeah
i want this i watch somebody all the
time how did i not think of that
immediately
i love it i love it song you want to
continue there yeah no no because look
you guys need to follow jimmy for all
the things we've talked about up until
this point right
but our our audience may recognize him
from a recent video
i know that we can take somewhere
i talked about it so much okay no i got
the talkie points down
he got his points ready okay let's get
it if you guys recognize him jimmy is
the wingman yes on the um the austin
evans yeah yeah
if i stand like this
yeah your arm your arm was matching the
video shout out to your arm and a shirt
thank you
so i know we talked about this we talked
about this briefly when we when we met
up a couple of weeks ago but like what
what is the reaction sort of to you
being
after that hole so i don't want to call
it a debacle because yeah up and down
people had different opinions or
whatever but what did your profile
change at all like that no everyone
ignored me
so austin caught the smoke for the
cooling issue
you got free
the amount of people who came after him
was
tiny it was like a tiny amount of people
on twitter specifically on youtube
that video is like almost 100 positive
comments
great views great likes everyone's like
great thanks for letting me know like
this isn't it's all the people who
saw the opportunity for free views that
blew it out of proportion on twitter you
know how it always goes and then they
want to grind it like i don't know i
want client went out but you tech usa
man that guy hit it so hard you like the
pull videos
i couldn't do that if i tried
i don't know so that was funny because i
was dustin was uh dustin and i thought
it was so funny we were going back and
forth like we were watching all the
videos together and uh with lock the
shout out
we were all going through it and
i don't know i don't think anything we
said was that egregious because i know
about it at all i don't i don't austin
edited it so i don't know if he cut it
but at the end i'm like i know we said
like yeah if you're at the store and you
have the opportunity to buy the
the new one buy the new one like it's
not going to make that much of a
difference over time and
of course no one watches that part
like it's worse or whatever or they
infer that it's worth it and the only
thing we knocked sony on for it was just
not saying anything about it it's like
made a major change to your console's
hardware
and you're selling it for the same price
i just feel like
they could have said something like even
if they spun it in a positive way there
are a lot of way like this there's
absolutely no positive way to say that
we selling you a hot account hotter yeah
right
in fairness
digital foundry did come out and say
that oh yeah you know that it you know
it does it it runs you know as similar
it's not that much of a difference or
whatever but and the funny thing is like
why okay hold on not letting them get
away with that that's literally what
what they came out oh they said that
yeah did you see their second video why
i was just repeating what you mean
getting away i didn't do anything
uh oh we're just gonna poo-poo it uh
it's not that much it's just a couple of
degrees hotter no no that's not a thing
when when xbox was running at a uh uh
perceived
degrees hotter and then it came out that
it wasn't
oh
they're burning it up the heat wave is
happening and now the situation is
reversed so we're not pretty sure austin
started the xbox controversy too
[Laughter]
when we did our series hex video because
we we got to like we got the big way
earlier yeah i remember i saw the
picture you were in the building i loved
the look on jimmy's face when he says
i'm pretty sure
garbage is like the heating or like the
cooling and the serious texas garbage
town or whatever
that's what he says when i watch
jimmy when i watch that video all i saw
was like like awesome just saying yo
this is harder
that's all i saw
i didn't really see him like oh don't
buy this like all i saw was like
this is just harder you know and the
heat sink is smaller yeah the heat seeks
smaller the console gets a little harder
and he didn't even really act like yeah
i saw people like on twitter saying that
he said it's it's gonna shut down it's
like he never said that
that's their own people together clips
from other videos to make it look like
he said like stuff they straight up just
didn't say which is wild and you know
what our should uh is the ps5 worth it
video we did the review he is so
positive on the ps5 and the xbox gets a
lot of criticism which to be fair we had
the xbox for so long for a month so and
we were like we revealed it we got an
early unit we like got it again early we
had to send back our like beta unit and
get a retail one yeah so we had enough
time with that console to really pick it
apart with the ps5 it was all first
impressions and he loved it like he he
had nothing but good things to say about
the ps5 so yeah i don't know but you
know how to school yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know
you guys just you know you receive the
unit you know now they're they're saying
you're on the payroll
you don't feel it phil's got the lambo
outside your house
you know that's how it goes jimmy one
one negative comment yeah i love how
jimmy shut a lot of them down when he
was like look like for you saying oh i
didn't make this amount of content for
playstation i didn't get a review unit
like if i would have got a review unit
it would make more sense for you to make
that type of content because that's more
searched on youtube
which is like we wanted a review unit we
bought a dual shock dual sense uh same
thing we did with this new ps5 we bought
a dual sense for like a grant on ebay
and we got
we got the new controller like when
everyone like ign all these people had
their ps5s and they couldn't talk about
it we had the dual sense we did a video
on it and that pissed all them off they
came after sony and they were like
the videos out like people are talking
about this like duel sets like why can't
we and sony
called and you know there's like some
words back and forth and
the video's still up so take that out
you will but yeah like
so we we
light and you know what's funny that
video was super positive too we were
like this controller feels next-gen
do you feel pressured to um
if it's not a glowing review you know uh
these certain individuals will call in
are you implying that because any
negative sony uh comments are made that
that something may happen that there are
repercussions for them
they didn't get a review unit i should
feel like they should speak for itself i
can say
did get was like date and date and we
got to give the impressions right then
and there yeah i just feel that if
somebody's going to talk the truth about
something
and
they don't get a review of the unit
because they are fearful that the truth
is
i personally feel like when it comes to
the whole argument people was like oh if
they got review codes review units like
look like
in that case don't watch anything ever
don't look at anything
don't read any reviews don't read any
product reviews because all of these
people got review units for them right
that's that's what they do to channel
four but you know in in contrast
you had uh
two
uh xbox series x's you had a beta unit
and then you had the retail unit that
was okay listen you can review this and
then we're going to ship out this one
that is actually what everybody else is
going to get and hey
say with it as your wilt and
i just feel like that's a that's a
better practice um i don't yeah that was
way better so
i know even the people who got the the
review units for the ps5 got him like
really late like yeah i think like a
week i want to say i don't know it's on
purpose i'm gonna be real with you so
like yeah so just actually xbox did it
great so jimmy like if if you got a
movie to to talk about
and they gave it to you the day before
the movie came out
it kind of would like make you go hmm
right like
yeah that can work negative too though
because the first impression there's a
lot of moves where i see it in my first
impression i come out there like
yeah i don't know about that you know
what sits with you like malignant would
definitely be one of those movies where
a week later like you know like first
gut check on that one i'm like
that was nuts like
that was not what i was expecting and
then
you start to like it more as you think
about it right so with movies it's a
little different but i think yeah i
don't know like having the xbox that
long was sweet because
we could play xbox games we could play
xbox one games we could play 360 games
we could test everything on it and to be
fair sony there's not much you could
really test on that console with the ps4
games
like
the biggest thing that just like is
crazy is just like look like
people can't speak their opinion about
anything because it's like the moment
you speak your opinion you put in two
camps yeah you can't like
i you know i'm saying that
and it's just it's crazy how how the
industry works and you know i personally
feel like i don't know about you jimmy
but i personally feel like you know
there are scenarios where companies will
put out you know maybe not necessarily
consoles but i i think it happens a lot
in games really like let's let's give
them the review code the day before it
comes out so they're going to rush the
review and not really let it sink in
like
i didn't yeah i don't know firsthand but
dude i can totally see that happening
like
yeah i don't know with the ps5 i feel
like that console is coming in hot
anyway right like
no pun intended oh my god
jimmy i was there
[Applause]
i'll let you keep talking about it no no
no listen listen he's he's talking his
truth we got to let jimmy talk right
from the stage
saying something hold on sir
everything that i don't like about the
ps5 i was able to pick up on like
immediately
but that wasn't my video it was austin's
video it's his first impressions xbox
still his first impressions his video so
i can't talk to what he's saying but if
you ask me which console i would have
gone with
like day one
because i mainly play on pc i would have
gone with the ps5 but if you ask me like
which one was most buttoned up at launch
i don't think you could really make an
argument against the xbox series x like
that was
just it was i saw it so early too
running games great that yeah they just
knew what they were doing with it which
you know not to say that somebody does
it but i've had every sony console i've
had i'll be honest with you guys i have
a playstation channel so take it with a
great assault whatever
every sony console i've had ever has had
some critical hardware failure within
four years my ps3 blu-ray laser broke my
ps4 launch unit the fan went out which
was super annoying like trying to get
that fixed especially since you guys
know i have to work hard when i was
younger to get all this stuff absolutely
after i and then my ps4 pro the blu-ray
laser broke within a year and a half
which is nuts and then i'm finding out
they're doing the same thing they're
doing with this ps5 they have so many
different ps4 pros it's insane how many
revisions the ps4 pro they were and i i
just got luck unlucky i guess where one
breaks my vita battery went out there's
always something with these consoles
right
my xbox the 360 i got the red ring but
you got to look at the one i got it was
a used unit from gamestop selection what
refurbishments are they doing on that it
was a launch one and every xbox 360 got
the red rings it was just a critical
hardware problem ever since then never
had a problem with the xbox console and
i've had an xbox jimmy one
what i'm gonna tell you is um i'm gonna
tell you you know uh
get that other side and come over to us
and over here
from your own admission we've been
they've been treating you right so you
know the playstation's been breaking
down and you know uh jimmy i want you to
gain
[Laughter]
i only had one uh playstation mess up on
me and really to fix it to be honest
with you i always thought that hardware
was done really well i can't i can't
rely on that um my it was my playstation
3.
and i saw this like yellow light and i'm
like what the hell is this
what's going on but then they told me it
was the laser and you know they fixed it
really quickly i got it back really fast
um but i've never and i'm i can't i
can't lie on them you know i always
thought they their heart was pretty
decent but
you said that i was like
it's different for me because you know i
didn't have a lot of money so i was like
no like i don't like i'm not going to be
able to just go fix it if i can't pay
for it it's always out of warranty when
it happens
well guess guess uh guess i don't have a
console right now and that sucks
again
salute to you guys you know in reference
to at least pointing out one thing i
think that i think it's lost in all this
and to solve credit which i am glad he
brought up because i was i was
definitely not going to bring this up
solve force this issue is salute to him
for making a great segment because solve
does make great subjects what he does
but um i think what it is is you guys
don't get enough credit for pointing out
the fact that there even was a revision
because let's be honest without your
guys reporting regardless of whatever
cooling situation we wouldn't have known
the image change so i think yeah yeah
that's lost to this salute to you guys
for doing the research i did want to ask
um real quick i always stay along this
but when they when you guys with the
series x were you part of that with
austin part of that team when they got
it early like with jay serrano and
everyone in the room or was it how did
that work i was just curious about that
so there's a video on austin's channel
called building the ultimate xbox or
something like that it's like it's it's
got a cool thumbnail like all the xboxes
it's yellow
i wrote that video and i i went up to
microsoft and i interviewed a ton of
people there like so all the interview
footage you see in that video is me so i
wrote this i wrote like a book like i
could take the script for that video and
turn it into a book
and then
that was used like as like an example
like why we do good work right so that's
how we got to go with digital foundry
and do the um series x thing so i was
there nice that's that one i didn't do
much on i was just kind of there you
know like so using the rules no that's
dope new console
so that was that was just fun you know i
was getting paid to just hang out there
and then
by the time
every all the consoles came into work i
was mainly working on the second channel
this is okay and i was doing a lot of
editing there and that those are longer
videos triple cams the editing would
take up a lot of time so i was like in
the office but that was just largely
like austin just kind of doing his own
thing because when i was working with
austin
i was just like editor you know i was
editing most of the videos i was in i
was in the office but when when you're
editing
like 8k footage and all this stuff it's
it's a lot of work you know so it's not
like it's a fun job right it's a cool
job it's not like a regular job but it's
work so
i wasn't around for all the like most of
the fun stuff there but um
yeah i mean i don't know i'm not i don't
care like i'm
i think that's like why
people like sacred symbols why people
have like taken a little bit of a shine
on my channel it's because
like i i don't like if you criticize
sony they just get better and they
respond they respond pretty well to like
criticism they don't respond with words
they respond just like with silent
changes but
you could track like a lot of their
biggest controversies having direct
results on their future consoles which i
like i think that's cool like
prove it you know like don't just give
me words and say you're going to fix it
blah blah blah just do it and don't make
a big deal
there's a demographic of people
that feel like
doing stuff like that is a sign of
weakness
and they they need to stick to their
guns and i'm like no
you want to see me get defensive we'll
talk about
like
i'm like i could never do a channel
about like pc gaming or steam because
i'd get so defensive i would say stupid
but yeah the consoles are fun because
it's like you can look at them from the
outside and be like oh which is better
but i think xbox
has improved a lot you know so we'll see
you man and i know well they have to
improve if they're losing so yeah
i mean that's that's how we got the ps4
that's how we got all the best
exclusives on the ps3 that's how yes
like that's the ps3 not doing well is
why sony is where they are
remember a dude beginning of ps4
generation sony is like peak sony in my
lifetime yeah focusing on indies
focusing on awesome like niche
exclusives like bloodborne we'll never
get a game like bloodborne again i know
people are holding out hope
everything they're telling you they're
telling you right now they're saying no
big budget big summer games that is not
bloodborne like this is a
small dedicated audience like big for a
souls game small compared to sony's
other stuff so yes
yeah like when sony loses we win it's
like alien versus predator
[Laughter]
salute to you man again love the
transparency love what you're doing to
the space you know again the unique
combination with the producing the
youtube the horror filmmaking tremendous
history man we gotta move on and get
into these topics but i definitely
wanted to switch on that and uh solve
real quick do you want we gotta get
these super chats before we yeah let's
get it let's get them that minute okay
hold on let me run back for a moment
no doubt no doubt uh we have a
face 23 20 super chat thank you sir ps5
kraken tech is doing wizardry watchdogs
legion latest patch is uh 3.2 gigs on
ps5 and 40.2 gigs on series x do you
think this can be a problem for xbox
moving forward okay that's that's a huge
difference
you can actually have less space that's
god bless
the next question
[Laughter]
we got krugman five dollars in the chat
i listened to the lord during my night
shift but i had to show some love today
thank you so much sir
also two dollar crew once again to us
also new year
baby salute
the building then we have faisal asan
two dollar super chat have a great show
today lords thank you thank you so much
sir
we have sin vendetta five dollars that
fun fact the og xbox 360 model without
the hard drive was called the xbox 360
core system yeah
the arcade came later when they were
pushing live arcade and my whole
gigabyte right
broke system
uh we will all share the hard drive
then we have the mag five dollars with
the chat confirmed microsoft has
acquired spacex and take two oh
will be developed on mars
shout out to maggie we gotta get back in
the room bag's hilarious
then we have general mac five dollar
super chat oh hell the iop shout out to
king to lord kingstradamus for repping
the og with the salt and black pepper
beer okay that's that's only for today
the beijing or the just for men will be
happening
he didn't use too under the table to
make it through it that's what you know
that margaritas i mean the tequila was
lit last night i have a video i have to
do with the modelos you know you know
what it is
absolutely then we have rd 2 super chat
twitter spaces are now horse stables
with red bull wow okay oh that's for
okay so what he's explaining is i was on
game one daily yesterday and
that's a reference so inside jokes
yeah yeah watch the show
then we have sim vendetta again five
dollars in the chat yes i'm loving all
this switch slander come on nintendo
where's your achievement trophy listen
cog and i have been have been holding
the flag
on their neck
what are they holding the flag
[Music]
i know what grandpa is i ain't trying to
have them be something else no no no i'm
trying i'm putting a boot on that night
and prove your damn things stop
that's not gonna happen there we have
iron mike five dollars super chat king
king liked the last of us two story no
wonder he like malignant lois gets your
brother's smell
well you know um i understand that you
don't know like fine wine so i am i get
i get you i understand so
are you insinuating are you implying
that he drinks boons sir
two dollars super chat i'm roasting
y'all today with love okay yeah thank
you that we have peter once again get
the spam web champs back they
commencing with the smoke uh five dollar
super chat cog is broke because he buys
so many shirts because his massive
biceps tear all the ones he has boom bro
are you out here roasting
then we got
peter again five dollar super chat attic
has to have a desk job because he has a
bad back from carrying that giant iguana
oil is like jesus
i hear most of the laws and paying to do
it
then we have uh
five dollars which king it's like you
said people have become soft the people
that complained about austin's video
can't take any criticism of playstation
exactly this is absolutely a sad face
you missed one you're not missing the
the the king slander okay oh wait i
forgot to copy paste that one yeah yeah
yeah
[ __ ] the wreck
sideshow statues doesn't love you for
you they only want all that money that
you have in your face oh this this is
true i don't have any sideshow this is
like some please step your game up
yet so i don't know whether to be
relieved or offended but that's fine
i'll i'll leave it right there
let me see let me have let's put the
crest in the chat for lord starkiller
put the crest in
don't drive that stack so hard into my
blood-borne filled heart oh yeah the
snake the stake in the mistake is that
stack okay i know what i know sin is a
huge horror fair huge dark souls guy so
when when jimmy was talking that
bloodborne it hit the soul i understand
you're not getting another one play the
old one again
at least give him a 60 frame you might
get a remake no you might get a remake
in playstation 9. oh done what did you
say ain't no more playstations no
no no no
it's this is
going to be a cloud console man
[Music]
i heard it during malignant it was
spinning up i'm like what ghost is she
was like why why are you wow
are you serious yeah i was like what's
what's happening
check checking that out
with you i'm trying
starkiller once again ten dollars super
chat absolutely fantastic show iron
lords thank you my brother
appreciate it luke and then we have
stitch with the five dollars we chat sob
don't feel bad we just respect old
people just saying
i'll take that roast i'll take that
right
he got the classic pullover hoodie he
said try to let them bulls know if they
don't come correct this is what they get
he bought to throw him in the bushes
hoodie and then we got the log that zgl
zgl7 he got the snapback log net he said
salute to the lords or cipher poll 92.
he got the net gators so yo don't rob
don't do no criminal action exactly
don't do anything
when you run around with [ __ ] if
you're gonna do something be infamous
[Laughter]
oh yeah all right well man cypher paul
also got the snap back salute the offer
for supporting the merch and i think one
more came in we got yeah master clown x3
20 super chat next time say something
sir please we thank you appreciate it
put it regular we'll read it no doubt so
let's get into it so last week's poll
results are in the people has spoken
with the recent announcements of marvel
spider-man 2 and wolverine developed
exclusively for ps5 do you think xbox
also needs to have its own marvel slash
dc
aaa superhero game the winner at 52
percent of the vote pretty close
of three-way joint was yes with
microsoft's resources in reach there is
no reason why this successful genre is
lacking in their portfolio coming in at
second at 29 of the vote was no xbox
doesn't need to copy sony's template for
success it should continue to develop
their own diverse experiences and in
last place the messy lords 22 percent i
don't care but if xbox don't get hashtag
just one cog is about to flip on
everybody
to the messiness you already know some
of you are the victor this year yes sir
how are you feeling about the people
saying that they want you i got it right
you know why because the two things
don't need to be mutually exclusive it
don't make no sense why are there 130
billion playstation 4s out there it's
not because of nathan drake and it's not
because of uh ellie it's because of
spiderman
um
113 people 113 million people did not
buy that game stop acting like that the
people are smoking
w
people people bought playstation 4s for
the 2ks
to buy spiderman like there's a lot okay
people that did
they buy it did they buy it
because of spiderman more than because
of the last yeah
i'm just saying though
[Music]
let's have microsoft acquired wb games
all right yes
that'll be perfect
did we get the master yeah yeah yeah we
are no doubt
only successful
team is still talking about
what happens anyway let's get into it
man a lot of times lord addict this is
you
death loop man you know you probably one
of the ones the most experienced here on
the panel beat the game finish the game
finish the game so let's just break it
down that game came out
yeah it is happening
it is a ps5 exclusive oh and it came out
on pc it is on xbox god bless
anyway it's a good attic man talk to us
man a lot of stuff about this game a lot
of you know a lot of feedback so tell us
your experience man what's going on with
it um i don't know did uh jimmy did you
play any death loop yeah i'm like uh i'm
pretty sure you said you did hour and
how much two hours in
okay so i got the blink i've got the
double jump i uh
i fought juliana once
and i killed her it was it felt pretty
good
it's a good game and i'm it's exactly
what i wanted i don't know i was like
dishonored a little more focused and
linear because it's a shooter that's
what i want
with guns and i think they're doing a
good job the shooting feels
good i had to put the fov up to make it
feel right because you know on pc it's
got some issues with uh
it's yeah but i guess it's not really
stutter i guess it's just like how the
mouse movement works it's like
specifically with mouse and keyboard so
i i found out how to fix it with like
vsync or whatever but oh so you played
it on pc
yeah oh okay you played this this is the
first person
all right let's not let's go down let's
go let's let's we're here for addict's
review of this we're here about game
play
please please tell me more because i
like that mouse and keyboard thing
uh-huh
don't the normal the way we normally do
this is uh call guys some questions you
have any questions
so like pretty much i want to get into
obviously the the core mechanics of the
game and then i do want to ask you
not that there's a controversy but you
know obviously it's doing well but i
would be remiss if i did not talk about
by defining duke cole's bad mr maddie
plays he had put a video out he got some
pushback right and he's a huge arcane
fan in his opinion he said
great game but he just said that as far
as an arcane game he was slightly
underwhelmed you know what i'm saying
in comparison to the other masterpieces
that our king gets so
first the first question and then you
know comparison because obviously you
play dishonored all that stuff as well
too so the first question was about the
game yeah gameplay and the fact that is
it warranty like
the overall consensus is like an arcade
game okay it's definitely an arcade game
like
um i i like
thing they uh incorporated like a kind
of a multiplayer faction in there you
know jimmy was talking about julianne
attacking you so like pretty much what
it is is uh
there is
a ying to your yang pretty much and she
will just pop up at a random which is
funny there's only like five did you
know there's only five five or six
stages she can actually invade you on
during the day like time of the day like
she can't invade you every
and everything like certain she can only
do it in certain times that's probably
good
what's funny is like
the game's overwhelming at first like
extremely overwhelming but then once you
like start honing down what's going on
what you need to do then it's a lot
easier to like incorporate like go there
like you know
keep restarting this day over and over
again you don't understand why this day
is restarting you know you have to
figure out why you keep losing your
memory to it because you've been doing
this for a long time apparently and what
i like about is just like you know they
incorporated a lot of
arcane stuff into the game to where it
you know originally you don't have blink
you know usually when it comes to these
type of games the moment you get the
mark of the outsider for like dishonored
you pretty much get blink off the start
like that's the the incorporated move of
arcade games but on this one you don't
have none of that like you know you have
to uh every there's visionaries in the
game there's people it's in the trailers
it's not really spoiling you gotta
assassinate a certain amount of people
uh they all have these things called
slabs and their abilities okay and
pretty much all these abilities is from
dishonored just
slightly taller
okay and what's funny is like they
didn't i'm just like my biggest issue
with the game is like i don't even i
don't even 100 agree with maddie when it
comes to this but like i'm like if
you're going to take straight up take
blink and stuff from dishonored why
don't you just
do something different like
they try to have it be too much like
dishonored to me okay like because it's
just like you literally took blink and
instead of calling it blink we're going
to call it shift and i'm just like i
don't agree with that because it's just
like looking if you're trying to be too
much like the son just make dishonored
3.
[Music]
but
you know i personally felt like because
uh you know me and maddie talked behind
the scenes like would it come to like
the ending i would have liked the ending
obviously this isn't the ending but i
would have liked uh death luke to have
been connected with this on like when
you finally
assassinate all the people you need to
the outsider shows up and he's the real
villain and this has been connected to
dishonored universe the entire time
because i felt like if you're going this
above and beyond to put these elements
of dishonored in this game it makes no
sense that they're two separate
universes okay like because based on
this point that's what you say so you're
saying that it's so similar in some
respects that part you you wish it would
have been uh just a dishonored game or
like this name well it's not that i wish
it would have been dishonored i wish
that
it would have been in the dishonored
universe or like a connection
you find out that you know they don't
even really explain what's going on like
in terms maybe it's in like the the
handwritten notes that you guys don't
read that [ __ ] so you know
maybe it's written in there i don't
think it is because i did read a lot of
stuff in the game but it's just like you
know the slabs that all the visionaries
have like where did all that come from
like
and what's funny is like the way they
assemble on your arm they symbol the
same way the mark of the outsider is so
it's it's just like to me a perfect way
of doing that would have been like yo
let's let's go ahead and say that the
outrider is the one that gave them the
powers the outright is the one that
established the machine to do it right
but it is what it is like it seems like
minor-ish complaints you just don't see
like major like
this is an issue
i think it's an issue because i feel
like they try to be too much like
dishonored and it's not dishonored like
it would have been different if they
took the gameplay but everything else
was different like they literally have
the abilities from this audience
okay all right
and then the question i have for you in
uh two months
um
one in reference to obviously the the
time loop aspect i'm a person that's
coming from 12 minutes and you know
where you have to kind of learn more
about it through clues and stuff to try
to get to your goal like did you think
they implemented that well did you think
that was a good component to the game
and and also the um the invasion aspect
with the multiplayer
the invasion aspect um it can be very
frustrating because i feel like
i've always felt like arcane games
aren't designed to be shooters they're
designed to be stealth like games that
you can be shooters
but when you put another person
into that equation that can play the
game the way it's not supposed to be
played like when i see a julian pop in
because i never put this as friends only
i didn't put it offline only i wanted
that smoke so when julian showed up i
knew it was another person so what i
like is you don't know where julian is
and julian don't know where you are so
there's uh julian gets like this
notification if like an ai sees you like
colt but besides that you know
everything's pretty even so like when i
see a julian i don't try to shoot her
because i personally feel like the game
wasn't designed to shoot like that so i
will use blink and just sneak up behind
her because i'm not going to shoot you
eight times for you to run away get your
health back when i can literally just
keep dashing around the building because
you don't know where i am and just
assassinate you okay so you know you're
playing it right at that point like
yeah i feel like that's what you should
do
but you know a lot of these people
what's funny is you can tell a lot of
people are trying to like use this for
shooting mechanics like one time of
jolenes got stuck up on a hill and she
kept shooting down and she thought i was
gonna sit there and just play peek-a-boo
with a sniper on her all day i did like
the moment i saw her i went straight to
the left went right behind her you can
see in the stream she didn't know i was
there i just snapped her neck
but there is there is when you're julian
it is a lot harder because
when you're drooling you have to kill
colt potentially three times
okay but when you're coat you only got
to kill her once okay because she don't
come back to life so time loop
implemented well and then multiplayer
said okay cool and then
you've got to finish and now i'll ask
one last question
the time loop i think i
think the issue the biggest issue out of
the game was the ai and the way that
things look i don't like some people's
look like crystals i don't i don't get
that but
uh you know they i think that
obviously it was a more it was a budget
thing you know it they put mask on a lot
of stuff we saw that with compulsion uh
it's easier to develop if you don't make
individual uh people for uh individual
faces for everything and i get that but
like some of these designs have you guys
seen some of the designs like they look
crazy man some some people look purple
and i'm just like i felt like that was
the biggest immersion and then the ai's
not the smartest at all whatsoever okay
like i felt like if as long as you're
not seen in a certain district like
let's say a the
place a you kill everyone there you
could be you could you could just be
shooting everyone and trust me these
guns are supposed to make noise you're
on a small island right you go to to
area b which is literally right beside
area a everyone walking around like like
nine and a half oh yeah so you got to
suspend this belief with certain things
yeah and i felt like that hurt in a way
because like
the knifing ability like i can literally
mow down
a mad amount of people mad amounts of
people and then just going to the x area
just being stealth-like and i felt like
i don't know
i think the biggest issue of the game is
just emerging in terms of that because
it makes the game a lot easier when i
can just mow you down and they only take
a couple shots like you take a lot of
damage but they don't take much damage
either like almost one oh okay okay so
yeah it goes worth both way that's why
they have perks in here to give you more
health to give you more power power
mana whatever they want to call it on
here and i think that's the biggest
issue is the funding should a little bit
better when it comes to making
characters look a little bit more unique
and make sure the ai is actually
responsive i think that's the biggest
point and the last thing was just the
you know the big overall question
obviously it's getting raised you know
we've seen some 10s go out there and
then like you know with the whole
hierarchy and arcane like where is it at
for you with that with that
i think it's up it's on the same level
as dishonored uh it but at the but i
will say that without dishonored this
game doesn't exist okay
because i felt like you know dishonor
has always been about a arcane for the
most part besides prey i didn't like
prey but for the most part it's always
been about you know choosing your route
choosing the way you want to play
assassinating the people and doing
unique different ways of doing it uh
this definitely didn't really have that
for the most part i felt like you know
they were very narrow like this is how
you're going to do this is how you're
going to do that right that's one of the
biggest issues maddie has because when
it comes to arcane you're used to
choices and how you want to do the free
for yeah
what you
because they want you to kill them in a
specific yeah specific way guys it
doesn't matter like the way matthew and
i would have personally wanted is like
there's multiple ways to kill all eight
of them yes but you have to find them
multiple ways but on here to my
knowledge there's only one way to kill
anyone gotcha and people don't like that
because that's not like an arcade
to me yeah
i don't mind aspects from dishonored in
the game that doesn't have all the
aspects from this on like they gave you
aspects to kill everyone multiple
different ways but they didn't give you
aspects to kill
the eight people in multiple different
ways so i felt like that was a good
balance of both worlds no doubt shout
out to brat he said great insight addict
he said great points with the game they
agree with it being on par with
dishonored dishonored 2 has the same
metacritic no doubt shout out to
starkiller who just got that classic t
though i see you bro but um i don't want
this guy saw i want to get you in yeah i
want to ask um addict like so do you
think
because the thing about like the past
arcane games that as a fan of like the
the immersive sim is that they can be
kind of intimidating to people who don't
kind of want all those choices are
afraid to kind of get that that that
sort of fear of like what do i do when i
have this much choice
so do you think this game feels like
it's appealing to more people on a wider
scale because i would say yes it has
been distilled down because i think
yeah i think i think maddie's issue with
it is that like as hardcore arcane like
immersive sim guys it it it distills it
down to a point where it's maybe too
simplistic
has it been casualized yeah i don't
think it's been casualized i do think
it's more appealing to certain people
because right you know you can you know
what it goes is like the the more the
story goes the more the visual uh
because you don't know who any of the
eight people are at first right so you
have to constantly do leads to final
eight to find first you have to final
eight where are they who are they then
you have to fight okay i can't kill you
all in one day let me try to get some of
you to interact with other ways
and then you know you find that two of
them are having some love affair you
gotta figure out where they shack it up
you got to kill both of them at once
like i i i really you know i enjoy that
kind of aspect
but i do feel like you know because in
arcade games it's like this is where the
dude that you got to kill you got to
find out where he is how to get to him
and if you want the secret one where
right you don't kill him you got to
figure out how to do that too none of
that was in here they are very and when
and when you get that right when when
you get when you get there that's where
like you sit there you observe it's kind
of like hitman like you observe
where they walk yeah so in this it seems
like that's kind of been not kind
it's there
but you know with with the loop aspect
of it it feels kind of like a roguelike
type thing it also feels like all of
these things it seems like arcane
stepped back for a second it's like okay
people love our games but our games
never do super well
across the board in terms of they
they're putting sales uh before iop
started like it's selling well it's
doing well
yeah that's good let's go let's get
kicking because i'm curious i think he's
at the same point as me with with uh i'm
gonna assume
this might this is gonna be something
you're gonna wait on for gameplay
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
definitely not on the playstation um
definitely not definitely
i would have played it on the superior
uh platform like uh jimmy did the
september
um
[Music]
i could wait for it to come to the xbox
and game pass so uh no but thank you
guys for beta testing oh my god oh my
god here we go listen we do appreciate
y'all kind of beta testing there is some
issues in the game
those bugs out guys work
this game boys
like i'm scared to go in my menus
sometimes oh my god
sometimes like sometimes you have to go
in your menu to see like okay what's the
code to this what's the code of that uh
there's a lot of auto generating codes
where like it will let you auto generate
without looking at but there are certain
puzzles they're like yo you you've got
to bring up your maps look at your notes
and find out what the code is to this
gen to this particular computer
playstation can't bring up maps
there is a glitch right now i don't know
if it's on pc i don't know if jimmy's uh
dealt with it yet but jimmy's like
nothing i dealt with a few times where
like when you breathe
when you push the the little middle
button this button right here
like
it's it's frozen on that oh
what's funny did you purchase that
function because you know you have to
purchase the extra functions for the
controllers well the game was already
seventy dollars
well you know they do have the eighty
dollar game and that's the one that
comes with the button function that you
don't got
i don't i don't think that was uh i
don't think that was definitely
thank you man i think you're confusing
it with another game yes
i gotta ask you this king do you feel
this game you know despite being an xbox
game studios game do you feel this game
is getting a playstation bumped up
i'm sorry i needed to hear this
like this only with this controller with
the extra tax on it no
listen
do you do you understand how contracts
work
i love how contracts work
all right so let me interrupt you real
quick that's loop is 60. the 60. there
you go there you go
he has five at 60 really yeah that's
that microsoft oh i'm assuming
it's the microphone though it's the
microsoft look after yeah they
look i don't personally think that i i
don't personally think the
10 out of 10's is ridiculous i don't
understand what people give like every
time i see a 10 out of 10 all you're
doing is making me have more
expectations for your game right it's
just like look like in the world this is
a 10 out of 10. it's like an 8.5
starving for games bro
so it's going to be a 10 out of 10. man
if you slide a hamburger across the
floor to a starving man that hamburger
is 10 out of 10. i don't care what
anybody's saying sir they had ratchet
and collect and return this year sir
okay it's over with no i know
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry you guys that completely shits
on return
they actually use items
they actually use them sorry they
actually use the mechanics of an actual
roguelike where you restart the day over
and over again something like they
actually use it the way it's supposed to
be used you can there's a there's a
currency in the game called infuse where
you can refuse to keep things that you
that you would normally lose when you
die and restart the day where you keep
that stuff when you restart the day
there's nothing like that
for the most part
this is where it beats return and i just
want to actually minus the math sir no
no i'm asking you
i'm asking you since you played both
how many times have def loop crashed on
you
um
uh twice twice
all right and how many times has return
crashed on you
probably around the same if not twice
so it's a playstation problem
give it to me ask me which one i beat
and which one i haven't beat
which one you beat was you beat the
flute and i didn't beat return
yeah because you threw it away because
it didn't work because when i died on
death loop i didn't feel like i didn't
feel like that sense of loss but when
you die on maternal i want to uninstall
the thing
i mean listen listen first of all they
got really good games um i do appreciate
you guys going out and supporting it and
putting up those tens listen and without
you beta testers we will not get you
hold up
you know what's funny uh playstation and
playstation fans are low-key
uh funding
a death look two frags thank you
and this is right this is why they say
this is an xbox five yeah
does this become does this become part
of that quote-unquote legacy
that phil's talking about no sure
so we're saying def
to me if it was that way
we wouldn't be getting death loop
they've already said it's coming out
next year that was a one-year time
exclusivity that they
part two
part two is over here so like listen you
can play uh definite twice
you can play a second go around the
sequel
anyway salute the kid he had to hijack i
gotta be messy jimmy come on
pulls from so many great horror movies
that you got to give it credit like it's
like it makes prometheus cool again yes
it got me thinking about that movie
which you know prometheus was one where
when it came out people were
really negative on it thought it was
weird but as time has gone on they've
soft softened up on it so i feel like
with maternal you get you're getting
that head space like the precursor type
stuff all that really cool hr guy your
imagery yeah it's a really good gateway
to some good movies yeah also returner
runs
so good now it really is good launch for
me too
i know
just to clarify real quick jimmy you're
saying
return was a good game for movie aspects
and not for games well exactly because
it's important well just tell me exactly
what's pulling from that
so but death loop is also pulling from a
lot of different types of movies like
sending style stuff like how the suicide
squad just did you know suicide squad
stuff like that yeah clockwork
and you know to be fair to death loop
it's doing a better job than we happy
few i think like it's dialing it in and
being yeah but yes this game has a lot
of we happy few fills like it really
does definitely that 70s feel yeah and i
like that but if you're going for vibe
between the two i got to go with eternal
just because you know it feels like
return you get a little bit more reward
out of it i i'd say like return on
playing with the disneyland atmosphere
but no so what you're saying like where
you want to throw your controller into
the tv when you die after a long run
i live for that that's what i'm there
for i'm like right persevere over it
whereas on
death loop it's more of immersive semi
it's more puzzle-solving you know i
never feel really challenged by it i was
flying through
the first like it took me a very long
time to die in my first loop because
it's the same thing with wolfenstein 2
or when that came out everyone was
complaining that uh you know it's so
hard so hard but if you go for head
shots these guys go down and one hit one
yeah wolfenstein they're wearing a
helmet one shot to get the helmet off
and it staggers them so they're standing
in the same spot you just two tap
everyone in the game right you never you
never take a bullet and wolf inside if
you do that so you can kind of game it
in death loop you can't really game
return like you can get a little bit
more of an edge but
at the end of the day i feel like it's
me improving as a player right they got
me through eternal you feel the
challenge
i know i'm gonna beat it gotcha the
story is what's at the front so it's
like okay they're two different kinds of
games but i gotta defend return that's a
cool bloodborne style exclusive from
sony that like i don't know we'll never
see more of but it was really cool to
get it when we got it same kind of
timing as bloodborne too so like
yeah
i think you might get another return
after they purchased the studio after
the studio yeah playing the hardware you
know it was like shut them up uh we own
you know i don't say that again
i want more of that it sucks with the
horror on games i don't really get it
why triple a horror always feels like
it's fighting an uphill battle like the
last of us too it's going horror right
with the gore the hardcore like violence
and stuff like that you've got articles
coming out every day but oh it's like a
little too violent
i don't know why why does horner always
have to fight this huge weapon and as a
society have become more um sensitive
you know to certain aspects of it so um
i don't know i like i feel the horror
aspect when you talk about return and i
see it and i can i get the genre that
you're going for and being that you're
such a movie buff and you're such steep
in that uh aspect of it you would
appreciate things of it like you know
you said different movies and i love
prometheus so i did get that when i saw
it so i do understand what you're
talking about i can see your
appreciation addict you wanted to come
here say something before my biggest
issue i had with fraternal is like when
it comes to starting this the game over
and over again
i just felt like
the only thing i gained was knowledge on
fraternal like okay this dude runs left
and not right okay this dude
this dude throws these projectiles you
have to dodge these but you can attack
like you deflect these like i i didn't
when it comes to starting the the same
thing over and over again i want to feel
like i'm gaining more than just
knowledge when it comes to starting the
day over again like in hades okay i get
the knowledge but i also okay let me
unlock this so i can take this with me
too
so i could take it yeah it's a very
similar situation with hades and dead
cells so i'm like a dead cells
evangelist i'm like this is the best
this is like
straight up one of my favorite games of
all time dude and then hades i'm playing
it and i i'm dying not because of me i'm
dying because of the game and it's like
i can you get that feeling that the game
wants you to die at certain points so it
can advance the story like
there's towards the beginning because i
have to restart it every time i go back
to it because i
lose all the skill right you get to a
point where you're flying through rooms
and then you get to one room or you just
get stopped and then it's like i know
some big story moments coming up right
after this and then like oh suddenly a
new person's appeared i don't like that
i want the game to let me play the game
and the way that hades is constructed
you can't do it that way because they
they have to tell the story right they
want to tell it dead cells is like
you're this little worm you're like out
of this guy's body figure it out
that game you can just jump right in
every time you play it
you know why you died and you know what
to look for to not die the next time
around like that's my kind of that's
like why i like games versus movies you
know the game
like a good story is a good story i love
good story games obviously uncharted i
mentioned one of my favorite but i love
uncharted because it's the closest the
game really ever gets to giving me the
same feelings as you know the same with
the last of us like
you know
that's was too though big improvement to
gameplay i thought like going back into
the combat encounters i do that all the
time just to try and get better at it
because
when you get animation heavy games like
that sorry i'm just talking a lot
you you just assume that it's not going
to be tight or like responsive because
they're focusing on animations but the
control in the last of us too is very
good like it's very fine you don't feel
like let me ask you a question jimmy
when you first saw that trailer when
they showed the last of us too and they
saw ellie uh running she grabbed the
bottle she hit the dude in the head and
yeah i thought that was liverpool you
thought it was fake right like i thought
it was you can actually do it
yeah
yeah and then when you're you my
favorite combat encounter to replay is
the tv station because it's got
verticality you can kind of make a run
through it but you even if you restart
it you can have a completely different
run just because the the ai is so good
they're moving different ways they're
kind of interacting with each other
that's what i like that's the biggest
thing i felt like death loop was missing
if that ai would have been like on last
of us caliber the game would be
completely different i think part of the
issue where you said the game felt too
easy in a lot of moments is because the
ai was was low-key it like idiots like
just like they just imagine yeah being
seen by one and the whole island knows
you there you don't know oh man
that that's where i felt like i felt
like what was going to happen is like if
you kill the first one the other ones
would be light on to what you're doing
but you never really get that experience
i kill the first one the seventh one
doesn't acknowledge i killed the first
one you know what i'm saying so yeah i
heard the bodies disappear after a while
though right they do that's another
thing no they disappear almost
immediately okay like you snapped their
neck they're low-key already
disappearing before they hit the ground
whereas in dishonored you have to earn
that you earn it you have to hide the
body right
i understood that because it made sense
to the story because they're in pretty
much a virtual reality kind of way like
they're reliving the same day over and
over again no doubt absolutely i'll jump
in real quick um i'm kind of
surprisingly with king that i am going
to wait
you know
you have it on your console sir yeah but
my backlog is crazy right now and i
can't justify my only thing is i think
right now
with 12 minutes hades like i'm kind of
like overload with the roguelite and the
time
i guess
i'm like i just went through i think the
reason i gave this is because it was
arcane oh yeah no shut up
salute salute gotta give them they
flowers but i think for me it's like
obviously when i know this is gonna come
to game pass at some point
you know when the exclusivity window
after a year then for me i'll catch it
on there you know you know knowing
microsoft some type of fidelity upgrade
or something maybe in the vein of
hellblade how they did what uh how they
would probably get whatever expansion
you might get at the same time as well
exactly yeah and you probably need to
really do 4k because i heard it was like
1440p what happened well that's what you
heard
something like that yeah but uh look i'm
i'm i'm happy it's doing well i'm happy
that because let's be real arcane games
for the most part generally sometimes
they're not the biggest sellers though
right so i don't like they that's the
thing yeah that's the thing
well the second one sold like half of
the first year so to me it's like little
salute give them their flowers they got
one people are really into it i like
that aspect and you know like i said
it'll hopefully come over there pretty
soon after the exclusivity and i'll be
right there for the free 99
yeah yeah you know get that job
people in the chat like look this i feel
like this is the that loop is worthy of
that dishonored like caliber game but i
don't think that they took it further
than dishonored i think they just took
what they learned from dishonored and
they they expanded on it a little bit
making like a groundhog day thing and
that that's as far as it goes like i
don't think it's like a system seller i
don't think you need a ps5 to play
deathly you got a pc play it over there
with jimmy like you know you don't got
to go above and beyond to play this game
but if you got a playstation you like
arcane type of games then definitely
pick it up pick it up and like i said i
see a lot of people like this so salute
to them definitely pick it up uh buy
more of it i want the game to be part
two on xbox and i want you to join me in
the game
that would be crazy just to talk about
that real quick if there is a death
below 2 and it is on xbox only it is
going to be crazy how twitter verse is
going to change because now the people
that are supporting death flip are going
to be saying don't support that flute 2
and vice versa
that'll be interesting to see
if we do announce it too but let's move
on solve some chess then we'll move on
to the next
oh yeah give me one second
um
we've got hold on to go back a little
bit
let's have micro okay we did
let's have microsoft acquired wb games
right we said that yeah yeah so yep
okay uh
cheney five dollar super chat so is uh
what if it's right ea and take two being
bought by microsoft iop book of acts
field dominance says that every every
meme that we have is in there um they're
really going for the stars
these aren't even the stars like this is
like this is like some green lantern
stuff
and we got cheney once again five
dollars
well well well
some of the best games on playstation
are made by xbox here we go who has
bangers
like
book of acts let's be real though king
is he wrong
no he's telling you
[Laughter]
the streak is on fire
fights i'm the best uh um baseball
simulator on xbox game pass made by i
knew
that sony uh acquisition that studio
sony acquisition
all i'm saying is playstation's eating
pretty good off xbox studios right now
that's all i'm saying and we eating
pretty good off that baseball
continues
all right then we have um alvin five
dollars death loop plays great on pc
with a controller the stuttering you're
hearing is only only occurs with mouse
controls that is actually box elite
controller ftw yeah so i guess something
with the way like jimmy was saying like
it's the way the controller sort of
works then we have flame five dollar
super chat surprisingly no smoke i'm
very proud of you flame i'm probably
playing going through something right
here salute the floor
yeah flame going through some but salute
to him man good to see him
and we got cypher pole 192 five pounds
super chat don't worry king infamous
smoke coming in hot with that neck gator
just like the new ps5
i thought this was a good game i really
loved those games
yeah fantastic i love those games i hope
that thanks back yeah
then we have [ __ ] the five dollar
super chat i guess he heard me i don't
listen to iop around my wife because
when saab talks with that velvet voice i
have to mop the floor again in your mind
wow
i don't know what type of relationship's
going on there oh my lord
getting a little red in the face here
then we got it
drawn tj five dollar super chat lol
awesome show guys i'm dying and i just
woke up that's the plan
that's the clown five dollar super chat
master clown thank you sir appreciate it
and we have kids with the three dollars
super chat savvy it'll be similar
situation to outer world yeah so that to
my question of do do we does that become
legacy someplace else everyone is in
agreement that it's not going to be so
much
bye
bye
[Laughter]
we're good we did not miss anything
throwback yeah we're good all right cool
let's get into it man so uh yes um looks
like it's uh
acquisition season it's cuffing season
again i mean we're
close on the one year what is it
anniversary of bethesda and the streets
are talking about rulers what's what's
happening man was anything happening is
it cap
well you know as is often the case when
when one one of the big three makes an
acquisition then you start hearing
rumblings from the other one so sony has
made some acquisitions in recent weeks
that you know obviously is going to get
the xbox sort of uh
churning a little bit the xbox community
and it started popping up again with
some rumors of xbox announcing some sort
of big big acquisition like bethesda
level acquisition
um sooner rather than later and that
doesn't necessarily mean like the next
couple of weeks or whatever it could be
months but apparently
that started sort of bubbling up online
and then uh some people in the know are
sort of shot it down some people that
know just don't want to hear about it
anymore they're tired of speculation um
so i'll leave it to the xbox insiders on
my panel because i yeah i'm not one of
them
ain't no one here
ain't nobody
they paid me too much not just
what do you guys think like i know
maddie put out a video a fantastic video
kind of talking about what what it could
be um a lot of people are tired of the
speculation a lot of people are tired of
it because
if it does come to fruition and it is a
bethesda-style sort of sort of
acquisition then the the old sort of
conversation about the consolidation of
the gaming space and why it's bad starts
to come up again right and obviously
microsoft are the ones that are
in a position yeah microsoft are the
ones that are in a position to make
that level of acquisition so what do you
guys think is this fake news is
something actually bubbling
and if it is who do you think would be
on the table before you jump in i just
want to for context so a lot of this
started with um okami was it akami games
yeah and um you know in the past he's
had obviously some reliable sources and
things of that nature and then
everybody kind of had their own tea
leaves that something may or may not be
happening that's major i just wanted to
give him you know as one of the people
who kind of started it and then he
tweeted some sources i think acg was in
there a couple other people was in there
but um all right what you thinking man
you want to jump in
i think that you know this is true i i
i like the senses i'm getting it's
supposed to happen this week like i
don't know if that's true or not like
it's supposed to happen sometime this
week
uh you know it might be next week i i i
saw some rumors going around like was
like a month ago that something was
gonna happen in a month like but like
the acquisition that the people were
saying on twitter is they didn't say who
it was so you know people didn't know if
it was sony playstation nintendo
ironically three weeks after all those
rumors going around microsoft's about to
announce uh you know a
industry defining move i don't know what
that means uh but i do want to point out
that you know i've been on this uh this
pedestal that microsoft's going to uh
buy sega
and uh and i do want to point out
exclusive we already have first
no no i mean i've made multiple videos
oh
you're standing
there's a lot of things that still point
towards that sammy's separating their
finances with them all of a sudden
like like you only really feel like you
do that if you're about to sell that
that party oh i didn't know that that's
crazy
you you got you got literally pictures
of people erasing sega off their
buildings in japan
yeah tgs coming you put the tv together
uh to my knowledge
have we seen
a sega game leave game pass yeah
yakuza like
like a dragon y'all all the others are
still there
the first judgment hasn't jumped in
right yet
we get a persona what are we doing let's
go all the way with it
i think what's that would be crazy
to me
there's a lot of difference like
especially them removing sega logos off
of japan buildings yeah like the only i
know about the pachinko building
no there's multiple buildings yeah no i
know no the main building they have like
in downtown tokyo is the pachinko
building and you know that's when they
were separating that whole thing what
you're talking about soccer guys
and that's you know i wanted to like the
final fantasies with the game pass some
of them have already left yeah uh but
yakuzas have been there for a minute and
none of them have left none of them have
unless someone in the chat tell me if
one of them's left but to my knowledge a
sega game that has winning game pass
have not left that service yet and it's
been enough time where you would think
one at least would have left by now so
like to me
so we get this announcement that they're
going to announce something that's on
par maybe not on par with with bethesda
or something around that
and it's ironically being rumored to
happen next week
a week before
tokyo game show okay okay it's just like
and then not to mention
we there was a timed exclusive on the ps
uh the the xbox series x and ps5 version
in the states on like a dragon it wasn't
on playstation 5 for a year
we got we got exclusivity to the um
what's that online game uh oh
yeah
that still hasn't been talked to your
credit um
i believe correct me if i'm wrong
football manager
which is huge it's a huge sim game and i
believe the newest one is launching in
game pass and that's a big deal i know a
lot of people like from an international
perspective like that is madden that is
people like that game i know a lot of
people estates probably maybe don't know
of it i don't care of it but i did hear
that i did hear that so that is
interesting to your theory that you
think something's bubbling would say
i'm not saying
that nah nah bro we going live with that
i said it it's a wrap hold up i it might
be like an extensive
partnership but i'm saying that the fact
that you know people you can't buy sega
you can't buy sega they're publicly
owned company sami's a publicly owned
company they own second it's not the
other way around
yeah if sega if sammy wanted to sell
sega they would separate their finances
like they did now and sell that company
off company public companies do it all
the time okay listen so to me
i feel like if they don't do it
it
look
people didn't think they were buying
bethesda
and then they bought bethesda like the
fact they bought bethesda
they could easily buy
and to me when it comes down to it like
look
i don't think they need no more cut like
if they bought sega they would be
complete because they would have the
eastern games they would have the
western games and they would have x
cloud at the top to heat to hit the
eastern market and they'd have this xbox
series s and x to hit the western market
and to me you put all those games in
game pass imagine if they went on tokyo
game show be like or they did it e3 i
don't know if they would announce it at
toco game show but let's just say they
say oh
uh they show a trailer to persona 6. and
then
phil spencer whoever owns sega i don't
know who it is comes out and says
this is on our stage because we bought
sega with atlas and that's why we're
showing on our stage and persona 6 is
exclusively on play on xbox and pc
imagine like
yo like and to me
if you microsoft has been very vocal
about trying to be more appealing to the
eastern market how else are you going to
do that unless you buy eastern market
companies and sega is an easter market
company with multiple games that appeal
to that market
listen i mean i'm i'm for it i'm team
shake i want to get jimmy in because you
know he's the insider here i was talking
i was talking to uh
maddie about it now maddie's mad he's
the insider
dude
the only i don't so i haven't read up on
the rumor or anything so i don't know
how big the acquisition is supposed to
be yeah but i would kind of want it to
be someone smaller mid-tier like okay
devolvers who i was thinking because
the developer makes oversmiths here
they're not like it's triple a right
like good morning
but i do think they have they have
enough i do think they have enough
caliber in that indie space to make them
a big deal i'm at mid tier from like
monetary like me they're like esteers
we've seen so many of their newer games
go to game pass already like that store
was that or xbox exclusive at least yeah
and uh
that would be perfect because then
they can go out and basically be like an
indie producer for xbox right they go
find these like weird cool games that
can just end up on game pass and not
need this like insane monetary uh
buyback
jimmy let me let me interrupt you real
quick okay there's a super chat i don't
normally read the super chats that's
solved but dawn who talked who i
definitely butchered your dream we're
gonna move past right there uh multiple
sega games have come day one in game
pass lately human uh kind football
manager last year and this year there's
two point horse uh hospital halls he's
right so there's games going in there
game past day and day yeah sega has
already said that they they've been
loving the relationship with game pass
and how their games are really doing
well and then i just want to go back to
jimmy with the whole evolving thing
continuously
yeah so someone also mentioned that they
have zero studios yeah they i think they
might own crow team the guys who made
the serious sam games but they have a
lot of ip like they've got
good stuff and they're
good at going out and finding really
good indie games which a lot of stuff
ends up on xbox that turns out to be
good but devolver seems to have like
foresight with it so you'd be acquiring
them just to do work for you like to go
find cool games and you could kind of
just let them loose let them operate on
their own kind of like bethesda does
sec is weird to me just because i'm not
like
i'm not like into a lot of the games
that they put out
and careful you're doing a good job you
just don't just say this
no i've always wanted to try yakuza but
it's like they seem like a big time
commitment and that's
the one thing i don't have so you know
enough um i like the dragons like a
dragon should be the one you tried that
was my first one loved it bro yeah it
just i don't know what this is this
might be a stretch but it kind of
reminds me of when xbox bought the year
exclusivity on tomb raider the rise of
the tomb raider i feel like them buying
sega sort of like that where
playstation just kind of has this huge
user base already for these sega style
games like persona yakuza stuff like
that
and i feel like
outside of the twitter sphere with the
critics and stuff like that when the
uh yakuza games end up on xbox first
they don't get as much of a conversation
as they do when they're on playstation
because i feel like the audience really
drives a lot of that conversation
they're not showing up for uh the xbox
releases they'll wait for it to come to
ps5 so i don't know i just i get all the
reasons i'm hearing right they make so
much sense why xbox would buy sega but
i'm and i'm like waiting for a reason
that gets me excited you know i just
don't know listen you're in the sona 6
fan that's all you need to hear if they
bought if they bought
if we had like you know i don't know if
cogs gonna ask us like what company we
would want them to buy yeah that was
like an acquisition
the company i feel like would do them
the most benefit and [ __ ] playstation
at the same time would be
because it's competition like
when people move in your pieces you're
going to take those pieces
off
that would i don't think it would
devastate playstation but it would be
one of those scenarios that colin's
always screaming from the rooftops i
think
uh the next elder scrolls is going to be
on uh playstation because he personally
feels like game passes on playstation
before elder scrolls six comes out
and i personally feel like if they
picked up square enix that would be the
one
thing that they could do that microsoft
could do that so and he's like
all right so i'm going to talk to phil
we got to get that on game pass come on
let's get it over here we're missing too
much because imagine like they would
lose all their timed exclusives and now
obviously not what's going on now with
16. but there's no more going oh they
did that go talk to scoring let's get 16
on time exclusive let's get seven on
time exclusive there's none of that no
more and i feel like that is the one
thing that they could do is like we lost
final fantasy we lost dragon quest like
bring them over here let's go let's do
this they get with that which is dope
would be dave's x like if they could
bring that back
mankind divided is like so underplayed i
love that game i play it it's great i
played a lot around fall because it's
got a really good fall feel to it and it
ends on a cliffhanger so i don't know
xbox bought square onyx and brought that
back oh that'd be so sick jxx is one of
the few games that remind me of
dishonored employees yeah the that
newest one especially plays a lot like
uh arcane game no doubt king acquisition
season
what's going on what you feeling i'll be
back guys someone's at the door no
worries brother um yeah i i feel that uh
they're going to uh get a publisher okay
um
something some a company that doesn't
need too much oversight
uh that can produce games uh distribute
games
and um
doesn't doesn't his
i believe matt booty has too much on his
plate okay so yeah yeah and 36. um
no because you're talking about the
internal studios that's within the same
studios that branches out to 36. 23
seconds okay i like how you always add
something
we're not going to do that if
um anyway um if sony can have secret
studios so can we
secrets
oh my god didn't they have a black
studio that was actually going and
finishing off products stop come on
let's do it um all right so anyway um
36
again without pushing this narrative
whatever
again um i just feel that
it's not going to be a a little side
project it's going to be a big
acquisition um it's not going to be
capcom
capcom makes more sense with sony okay
yeah well the president didn't know um
yeah he just yeah okay one of the ex
presidents or ceos went over to sodium
like i said before um i think sony moves
like uh a mob type of uh entity
um you work really good with us
you're part of the team now i agree with
that actually yeah that makes a lot of
sense i actually agree with that and
they they they leave you outside the
room for so many years and then they
take all right let them inside yeah like
they have to have that working
relationship with you right for a while
and then they bring you loyal
yo go over there and he gets a job at
sony i'm like
buddy
what's that
yeah like
who does this like
so it makes sense why street fighter 5
was locked to that kind of relationship
and you know street fighter has always
been all over the place so when he got
locked to that console
i mean come on man
capcom really fits with uh what sony
plans are and i and i think capcom you
know i i think it works well there yeah
i agree right i really think so so yeah
what you're gonna get the streets just
talking they saying
take two that much i can't say
that's insane that would be insane
that's so insane i can't say
i can't say but uh what i can say is
what was talked about is
that it's going to be um a publisher
that has very cinematic uh qualities
okay so that that's it
i actually
look i'll jump in there before i go back
to solve um
i do think something eventually will
happen we listen they're in i don't know
if it's this week though exactly that's
that's literally what i was going to say
i just i don't know about this week
because to me
my thing is we know something's going to
happen because if the goal is game pass
and what is it two billion games just
this big
overarching plan to get game pass
everywhere then you're going to need
more than that
yeah
studios right so
i look at the deficiencies i look at
what makes sense i agree with king
that yeah you probably want someone that
is self-contained that's the beauty of a
zenimax deal right they were
self-contained they can run their own
thing mad booty does have a lot in this
plate you know i mean with the studios
that they currently have look at def
loop yeah it's really doing really well
and i mean
self-contained studios yeah like i said
but this has been used to so it's not
much
micromanagement you need to do right so
if you're going to bring people in so i
agree you need to get something on a
bigger level you know sega is close to
heart obviously for me you know that
right as addict would say like that
would be a dream come true as a sega kid
sorry jimmy i know
it's okay i know this is okay it doesn't
please you but for me selfishly i always
got to say that but you know i've been
talking more people i think from the
thing that i
think makes the most sense that i would
love them to do is wb
because wb solves a lot of the problems
of deficiencies i'm gonna tell you what
superhero game superhero games number
one because stop stop if
they're able to get the license if
they're able to get the license i don't
think yeah right and if they can't they
obviously they their value to xbox is
not but they still but but that
rocksteady still has the chops to make a
game of that ilk so if you want if you
want to on this superhero crap oh forget
about that
was capping
we got to get kicked okay i got to get
you out of here
you were the same
who came in here with a spider-man mask
and spider-man and god of war ate this
and spider-man and now super hero crap
that's what we're doing you know
what i'm saying is
it's like everybody's getting this fomo
because they saw wolverine right and i
really don't think it's gonna it's going
to boil down to that but again i also
say that they have struck gold you know
they had they hit lightning in a bottle
how many times have we have crappy
spider-man games i don't know don't
forget the fog down on the floor and you
couldn't go so the answer for king is
don't make any superhero games at all
i don't think it's going to hit the way
you think it's going to hit all i'm
saying is it doesn't necessarily even
have to be a superhero game it's just
they don't they don't have any pop
culture popping game
that's the thing like
yeah like that they just at the end of
the day you need people to go
[Laughter]
go play legos
yo your refusal
ultimate superhero game guy it's cause
it's on that other side no
and you know what i go over there and i
play them
in peace you do
listen they hit lightning in the bottle
right insomniac made
a a perfect game in in sunset overdrive
that can show traversal and that game
translated very well for the spider-man
eye people remember the spider-man ip
was in the trash for sure up until this
point marvel actually made spider-man
really good absolutely they didn't get
cash in their body you're not wrong
you're not but do you not feel there's
somebody on the playstation side do you
feel there's no one on the xbox live
tackle
that can tackle it tackle and tackle a
game of that time
a game of that type let me ask you a
question
where is all this coming from because
you're so wolverine cgi no you know
where it's coming from we've been
how many crappy superhero games do we
have to go through until we get one you
know i think i think since the arkham
games that whole narrative has changed
since the arkham right you have batman
and you have spider-man
mm-hmm how many crappy games came out
there was a lot between that
there was a lot no one's saying it's not
a risk that dc universe stuff is
terrible
but that's all before that that's all i
was saying forget i don't even want to
just devolve into the superhero thing i
really don't want one right i know where
that's but this is what yeah all i'm
trying to say
is wb
would service multiple needs right and
if king would let me finish he thought i
was gonna go just to the superhero back
i really don't care about that anymore
i've already said what i had to say on
that but
remember netherrealm
fighting another deficiency right and
then what's that joint soft traveler's
tail the um fabulous tails
right so it to me wb is actually a
better fit for the things they lack
that's all i'm trying to say i'm not mad
if take two apples i'm not mad if sega
happens like all the stuff they could
use i'm just saying wb in a way is
perfect for a lot of things that they
need but i'm with king
i don't know about this week fam you
know
and my last point is um
usually deals of this elk that are this
huge
let's be honest joe schmoe around the
corner hearing about it yeah like that
like you don't say like to me like this
is like when we heard about bethesda it
was literally like the day before the
day of and then it's like bam like it
was while we were filming halloween it
like happened i was like whoa this is
crazy i'm like no
we heard about it we heard about
bethesda for a while you heard we didn't
hear about zenimax yeah like they went
and they brought the kitten caboodle
that's a whole different like aspect to
it and from from what the conversations
was before
this acquisition is going to be
larger than that so
when they was trying to go get discord
and it was paying uh 50 uh uh what
whatever
50 billion something like that to try to
get uh discord um i saw the rationale in
doing so right i understand the
philosophy and being directly plugged
into 300 subscribers right
this next thing if it rivals zenimax
in in scope
it's only like two players out there
that you can really say that too
and i just really want to don't want to
get that excited you know me neither i'm
bro i'm with you like you have no idea
we are we actually are on the same page
with this and my thing is
something's going to happen i just don't
think it's necessarily at the time that
the gamers won because i agree with king
that i feel that everyone is reactionary
to the show that happened and the way
business where business
they're not in the studio like yo they
just dropped that track right yo
right now hit him with the wp fam
stuff like that yeah good job he is oh
sorry
when you if you do it on the anniversary
and you do like you set an expectation
so next year people are gonna be wanting
like
whatever like
the anniversary acquisition season i
don't like stuff like that
going back to warner brothers they make
sense you said they don't get the ip but
that almost makes it better to sell the
studios because they can sell the
studios at microsoft and say yeah
license this ip from us forever now like
also warner brothers is doing some weird
stuff on the movie side like just they
just got bought by discovery right yes
warner brothers
when you have
a company like that buying warren
brothers for their movies that game
stuff as big as the money maker as the
game stuff is like that's an
afterthought at best to them and it kind
of could be seen as a problem so if they
see it as a win-win where they're like
we dump all these studios over to
microsoft which honestly let's be real
the studios kind of fit with microsoft i
think a little bit like a little bit
more like
you know like the the art style in the
arkham games it's like beefier yeah like
bigger dudes fits with like gears of war
to me i think yeah there's a
i think in terms of warner brother that
besides sega they're the only ones that
make sense to me because like what i'm
looking at i'm looking at like what i
personally feel like would benefit
microsoft the most like
they
they need a worldwide appeal that's why
i feel like sega is the one that makes
the most appeal because right now
if you buy warner brothers i do think
that they have a lot of answers
that they need like they need killer
instinct studio they need that
like i think that's the one they need
the most even more than comic books
they need they need their their their
foot in that fight because i personally
feel like
if sony buys netherrealm somehow oh god
they're done they're over
they got evil they committed yeah dude
that's crazy
i kind
yeah what's funny is king down here said
you know legos hey king you know who
makes the lego games
the people who own warner brothers
okay didn't they they just farmed that
out to somebody else didn't they um the
star wars lego thing but
at the same time again purchase in the
studio and don't have the licenses you
know i agree
it loses value
i definitely want don't want spat man i
don't want scott
like let's say that
because discovery they don't want
nothing to do no they don't want to have
money at all
so to me if you can obviously it's going
to be billions of dollars but you can
get that down for the low side
cheap
and you can get even if you don't have
access to those ips you have rocksteady
you could go find something you could go
talk to people making a spawn game they
could easily make the spawn game that
you need you don't go you wanna you just
deal with a car and hope for an engine
you don't do that but it's like
like the ip is everything these guys
i'm actually kids
if you buy warner brothers you don't
have because they don't get the mortal
kombat because that comes with it they
even stated that last time they were
talking to them the ip only affects rock
steady for the most part because they're
not going to make it what about mortal
kombat that's that's interesting
so that's weird because like that's
gonna be a movie thing now like well i
think you know
to me to but but the the ips only really
affect rock steady
the the the batman stuff like i don't
think they're gonna make another shadow
of mordor or anything like that it only
affects that once harry potter but but
but
yeah but really man harry potter
the harry potter game that's on his way
is probably going to do
numbers that's crazy
at least we have spider-man and batman
to like kind of grasp that maybe
good harry potter game one talk jimmy
give them
if you if you so the way i find news
topics for ps ready is we go on apple
news you type the topic in so
playstation right and then i see all the
stuff these sites that are content farms
that like just look at what people are
searching for and generate articles out
of it they have been making articles out
of the one-year-old trailer for harry
potter hogwarts legacy wow for a year
straight and these are always top
stories like
every creature that showed up in the
trailer is listed here and like jimmy
tell me a good game though
uh the
the ps1 one is
[Music]
jimmy is that's no longer excuse after
spider-man and batman you you if you
have access to those ips you can make
good games you just got to stop for it
well that's kind of what i'm saying like
microsoft buys the studios they can
exclusively license the ip there's no
reason for warner brothers not to let
them do that and also if you separate it
out you get dc on xbox side
focus on marvel it's just like
that creates competition and makes
better games i just i i do agree that
they do i do also i like marvel stuff so
i
i do agree that they need a comic book
here i do agree that i don't think it's
going to be marvel because why go for it
but i don't think i don't think that's
on the table to me personally i feel
like sony has bargained that spider-man
movie license into a we get a pic and no
go
because if you look at it everything has
been an exclusive in terms of disney on
either nintendo
or sony name something on xbox and i
think sony doesn't care if it goes to
nintendo they care if it goes to xbox
and i really feel like when they went
back to that renegotiate to get
spider-man back in the mcu though okay
well you know we'll negotiate on that
price but what can you do for us in the
game wise and i think that's where
wolverine came from i think that's why
you won't see anything else on xbox in
terms of those licensing because i think
sony done low-key behind the scenes
locked all that down
yeah i was convinced that when um you
know indiana jones was announced i
thought that meant that all right
disney's looking at it like sony gets
our marvel stuff
xbox gets our lucasfilm stuff but now
we've got
there's all the republicans
exclusive type
it's just that no
it's just no
okay so
stop with the wb stuff it's that's uh i
think it makes sense though no like it
makes a lot of sense that it's not going
to happen like but the idea even if you
don't get the ips you still get talented
i don't want to make good games i don't
want that you got someone to make kills
i don't i don't you don't want to
studios i'm not going to purchase a car
with no engine and hope i can get it who
did you watch
who you wanted yeah king they say i'm
curious yeah i really think they say
no
you don't even know no i i know i
try not to say something see what it is
is you want me to do that
no i i'm generally no no i'm not i'm
talking to addict wants me to no no but
but at the end of the day like this is a
conversation about what i would like to
tell you what
officially yes yeah ea
we got the movie
no no no no no no
right mary when you getting all the best
they got the partnership it's fun it's
friends with benefits no sleeping i want
i want i want to do
what they did
to us oh you are mad and ripped off you
want to be like ripped off their
platform
i want you want to play madness
you got to come over here get over here
okay get down on lay down it's on xbox
and pc god bless a lesson let's see you
later let's entertain this ea imagine if
they did that this is how you sure use
games with the did you is this how you
want to play madness
listen y'all just asked me this that's
not that's the wildest thing that i
could possibly come up with it's one
thing that i'm hearing i i don't want to
say anything
but at the same time if that thing
happens
incredible right solve before the wrong
topic gotta get yourself what do you
want
i mean like everybody's touched upon the
like the big ones they but but there's
two that i want to talk about real quick
that
also sort of fill voids that make sense
because of
where we're at now the games that are
popular right now so the first one is is
bandai namco right
right obviously souls
souls
souls has permeated every single type of
game genre like it sold
everybody i don't think you get souls
because you get that like from software
publishes with them they don't own any
of that do they
right it is a publishing thing right so
you would have to get from right that's
that's a whole nother thing they got
from i would love twitter i would love
to oh twitter
it would be crazy but it would be great
i think the world would end yes
the fighting game option that obviously
gets filled by tekken and and soul
calibur right like that's
didn't even think about that you're
right you think about tales of a rise
and how and how that hit very well they
get the tale series as well right the
tail series seems like it's like in a
renaissance that's my question how much
of that do they actually own
publishing all that they're publishing
all that but it's kind of been exclusive
right so when you when you negotiate
with one
it's probably on the table to negotiate
for the studios right
well it's easier to make that sort of
request so
how how that can happen it would it
would be through namco through band
dynamco anyway right so it's not you're
not you're not having that direct
discussion with anyone else so that's
one right that makes a lot of sense now
another one of them doesn't make sense
at all
but it's a pie in the sky thing
there is a publisher out there right now
that is
hemorrhaging goodwill left and right
just hemorrhaging goodwill are you
talking about cd projekt red no no no
not a publisher
that's activision blizzard whoa
i can't think right right now i don't
know if it's uh yeah yeah but again i
think i think microsoft
letter right
i think microsoft it has that sort of
cleansing thing over there no they do
not actually
know absolutely
let me have that isotope please
what you're gonna say because god this
is the thing right cod i wouldn't make
cod exclusive i would i would do what
cog what i did with minecraft i don't
want to lose sarah bond to become this
the the head of activision
oh my god
that in terms of reach and in terms of
bringing that that name back to a place
of prominence
they could do it whether they want that
burden that's a whole nother and that i
doubt it right yeah that would be big
reason
even before even even before
the uh all the the crazy stuff that's
going on i still don't think they would
have wanted something like that because
it's radioactive isotopes don't touch
that
it's always so you feel the same way
about ubisoft then
i don't think ubisoft's on the table
either i'd be so bummed
like i don't know
ubisoft ubisoft would make sense in a
lot in terms of when it goes to game
pass they do nothing but make gains as a
service they buy yeah they get pretty
much service
model
they they're putting diesel
in a car there like they blow that up
so that's what you got yeah that's what
i got man i i don't know it might be
smaller when they talk about like like
industry shifting or whatever
maybe they mean a particular developer
that's been associated with another one
of the big three and not necessarily a
publisher right maybe one big developer
that's kind of you you recognize as
being with sony or with nintendo and all
of a sudden they've been on xbox that
could that can mean a lot too so who
knows
let's see
you gonna be
i don't think this on the table but if
that ever happened god bless that little
doubt
he's open to all of it
random question um jimmy uh my boy
wilmie said um was you on the film set
for halloween that was his hometown in
uh wilmington he just wanted to know i
saw that i didn't wonder if you guys
know i was we were shooting our fan film
at the same no they weren't shooting
anything at that time oh okay yeah we
were shooting our fan film
then oh yeah yeah wilmington's where
they shoot uh
halloween it kills and they're going to
shoot ends there january no without no
doubt good spot good spot good spot yeah
so far super challenging final time
let's get about here yeah
where we officially get messy with king
because uh-oh i know
look at his smile
it's coming he's waiting i'm going to
pull the topics back up
[Laughter]
in my dm's
uh i'm rolling back a little bit just
really it's just fantastic
for a little bit yeah i'm saying no
doubt no doubt
shout out to everybody in the chat i
think somebody bought some drip so i
could shout them out with the drip drip
no doubt let's see oh yeah shout out to
the beanie anonymous put your name in
there man you gotta got that [ __ ] you
don't want to be you don't want to be
your own girl
that dislikes the podcast exactly it's
probably it's probably best that you
don't tell us
you don't need to call the authorities
it wasn't a ski mask
there's a guy with a wolf
mask my god
all right ready to rock let's go let's
go
uh we got michael aka best size fine
this is two dollar super chat
playstation is trash god bless wow
he really drops the mic and leaves
that's what we doing
[Laughter]
microsoft needs to buy take two
partnership with ubisoft for plus buy
sega partner with capcom and buy wb
games while buying gaming rights to all
of the dc extended universes
snapped everything into existence like
literally if that happened
that's
[Laughter]
to be chat if there's a japanese
acquisition happening i'm going with
bandai namco as being it recent activity
makes me believe it is them plus they
make the most on paper sense for
microsoft
yeah
i'm about there
the gaming community should be thankful
for microsoft xbox for being in a
position to keep ish away from 10 cent
and google you're welcome
ain't really trying to do nothing right
now with the that government sorry
yeah they they're kind of their their
stock price drop because uh yeah yeah so
much money
jd gamer five dollar super chat
microsoft be the behemoth that you are
think like nintendo gotta catch them all
have these xbox has no games ps fanboys
out here crying salty tears oh my god
how many studios do you need
then we got jd gave him five dollars in
the chat
sega was almost bought by microsoft 20
years ago them getting bought now would
just be the fulfillment of the sega
promise the sega fans that went to xbox
oh for sure
revenge
then we have donald taku oh the uh attic
read this already shout out to you
then we got gerald mack two dollars
super chat microsoft should buy the
embracer group yeah okay
the warm embrace we got uh urban ninja
five dollars super chat strangely takuya
takuya series director may be leaving
uh yakuza
that can take him from there okay yeah
he's apparently that's in the works that
he's leaving
to work for i forgot what the hell their
name is oh yeah we have cowboys fan 10
super chat if xbox gets another major
studio under their umbrella phil spencer
going to have to change his ringtone the
cool mode how you like me wow
okay okay
now we got four eyes malone five dollars
microsoft buys another big publisher i
think they got one more before the
government starts shutting them
start
down
this
then we got uh
for malone microsoft by sega can we get
a power stone revival yes please but
seriously can microsoft make good games
with the studios they currently have
first quality
[Laughter]
and we got jd gamer again 10 super chat
microsoft should bankrupt these
naysaying playstation podcasts while
taking a bath in all the salty tears
bound to come out of this one big bang
take little bang don't play with me
wow who said that jd game
brett bigger once again five dollars of
attack microsoft should just buy
nintendo uh then via proxy control their
own controlling stakes twenty percent in
bandai namco square enix koei tecmo and
konami
crazy that makes sense then we have snow
dragon five dollars for chat round table
acquisition next week
we shall see
jd gamer once again ten dollars of a
chat sony out here barking attacking
doing their thing but they're an ankle
biting poodle
microsoft is that big rottweiler
watching you daring to step a foot in
the door don't do it somebody don't do
it wow
jimmy's looking at this like i can't
believe it
he wasn't smoked
[Laughter]
embrace your group has 240 ip's 80
development studios 8 500 employees 40
countries all hail the iop yeah that
would that would be a a global reach
that would uh be interesting yeah we
shut microsoft down
makes the most sense on paper for a
japanese publisher they have anime and
toys to market to future generations of
japanese gamers too
makes sense for someone i mean trying to
even touch that anime market will make
sense
yeah yeah
then we got brett bingham again five
dollars a chap it's xbox's 20th
anniversary i highly doubt we make it to
the end of the year without a major
acquisition to celebrate okay could be
it could be
we got kids move okay chad
as a selfish guy i prefer ubisoft i do
take two for bragging rights i would
only do wb if the dc license comes with
factual why would that don't want that
brett bingham again two dollars from
checked wb games also has the old midway
games ip
okay
oh yeah the classics they do yeah they
do they do got the classic yeah somebody
wants to play uh centipede
target
yo you would never hear the end of it if
they started bringing those back like
new new long game pass
get that robotron
wb game studios doesn't have wbips it
would be a big problem current games
include harry potter lord of the rings
and easy extended universe facts
then we have kids with the eight dollar
super chat king's analogy is bad in my
opinion if anything devs are the engine
and the ip is the shell king
okay whatever you want to say you're
going to buy
yeah we jumped a couple hold on a second
i'm gonna roll back a little bit i got
it okay i got it we uh edwin sweater two
dollar super chat i'm campaigning for
tmnt for xbox okay yeah nice
jd gamer once again ten dollars from
chat okay so it's square this is why
sony has locked up final fantasy and
other ips for as long as they can
because just like death loop and ghost
wire tokyo they knew they'd never see
another game
shout out to jd gamer for doing all
these that would be crazy
[Music]
squares that we got drunken ninja two
dollars but yeah xbox needs netherrealms
lockdown mk and make killer instinct
then we have rob jones two pound super
chat ten cents got no sense okay
all right
we got rezzy mobile five dollars of
attack peace to the lords great show
great guest and jimmy champagne
i hope microsoft buys sega and take two
with the money in their sock bless y'all
is phil smith you're going with the
tiger hold on hold on
alexis uh evolves seven dollars will
check at the end of the day i play games
because i love to do it there's good and
bad and hopes for better things to come
from both systems no doubt all right
let's do that your final topic this
should be pretty quick um
king i know he's got all set up for him
this is the geforce now database leaked
which has definitely rocked
the game sphere this week lastly
man yeah i'm not going to go through the
list it's super long but it's it's it's
a lot can you send me the list
yeah after i finish reading it oh that's
what i meant yeah so the whole thing is
pretty much you know a lot a lot of
unannounced titles we saw some uh pc
ports from um playstation i think god of
wars on there we saw some major stuff
crisis for i mean crazy games you know a
lot of stuff going on now since then
nvidia has uh made a comment and a
spokesperson said it's an unauthorized
they're unaware they're aware of this
unauthorized published list and they
basically took immediate action to
remove it and they basically tried to
say that the inclusion of this list is
no confirmation that only got fired
yeah
i want to know i wish i could have seen
that happen yes
it'd be like robocop when the guy gets
shot out the door
so look this is a big one king i'm gonna
give it back to you man you seem to take
interest in some specific white horse i
wonder what i wonder why
quite delight like the light
i told you i'm 95 percent
[Laughter]
lamarcus doss i remember his name he
used to be up in there he would say
that's never going to happen i remember
i have you know listen um shout out to
nixon still close to my heart
one of the best acquisitions from sony
studios but again um all these white
papers that come out is from nvidia uh
during this covert time right now when
they're sending over people to do
patches and to help uh devs work with
their games trying to port them over
they want because they're leading the
industry in video cards um they have
privy to what games are being worked on
and stuff like that um this list doesn't
surprise me in the lease at all
uh it does
it does make a lot of people angry
and i don't understand that um just like
jimmy champagne likes to play games in
the highest fidelity um
on that pc but us
i really like to see god of war in its
true light not checkerboard um and and i
think that's a possibility and that's
gonna happen but again you know jokes
aside listen everybody knows this stuff
is gonna make it over to the pc is uh
open money over there to be taken uh for
people that will never buy a console all
right so stop being selfish trying to
hoard it all to yourself people are not
going to buy console they want to game
on a higher fidelity platform and how
they want to choose to play and sony
recognizes that microsoft recognizes
that other companies should recognize
that in nintendo uh please just go get
the money whatever let people game
wherever they want to game i know that's
hard no doubt so let's get jimmy in here
man that geforce leaks database do you
believe it what you're feeling what
you're doing it's gotta be real right
like it just seems there's the one game
that really stood out to me as like
confirming this list is real is hell
divers too
i love that game on vita specifically i
used to play it all the time and the
fact like that would never come up on a
fake list right like that's just so out
of the limelight so obscure so out there
that i feel like the inclusion of it is
what really confirms the list and
i don't know i'm happy i really
really want the playstation games to
come to pc because like i'm a
playstation fan because of the games
mostly
and if i can just play them where i want
to
like this is getting into it i have a
gaming laptop right with like a 3080 in
it it runs everything great my favorite
thing to do is play open world games
throw like a horror movie on the tv and
just knock off side quests it's like go
go sushima monopolizing my tv right like
that's where i get
like i i can't do it i can't sit with
open world games for a month straight
unless i can have something else going
on and so that'd be
so ideal for me hearing crysis 4 coming
back i'm like i hope that happens
because
i don't know i feel like crisis one was
excellent i think it's
good two they they had to really pair it
back to put it on console so it feels
like a
weird game but then three they kind of
got back to where they should be and
then they're like all right we're done
with the series it's like no you were
just you were just doing it like
you got there so i realized i would
really like to see that yeah come back
um
yeah and then i see the screenshot in
here with like the interface of geforce
now with god of war it looks so real
i want it to be that's that's where i'm
at but like
we knew demon souls was coming right
because they had it in the trailer they
had yeah yeah they magically said
yeah because and if they weren't
bringing all these games to ps4 i'd be a
little more skeptical of them coming to
pc but it's like they obviously aren't
scared to make sure make these games
come to other platforms it makes sense
right it's like free money yeah it is
like they're not giving microsoft any
money by putting god of war on pc
they're giving it to valve and sony has
a good relationship with val we've seen
that before with uh
portal 2 you got a free ps3 copy with
your
free pc copy with your ps3 copy so i
feel like sony's not really losing much
given that yeah 30 to valve because
people want to play these games because
they just make really good games yeah
absolutely absolutely i agree lord
addict you're feeling on the list i send
it to you
looking through it now there's things
that is kind of interesting like jimmy
said like the fact that halo online is
on that
uh i feel like if you were gonna make up
a list why would you put that on there
the halo 5 forged bundle that was on
steam why would you put that on there
like maybe it's just someone being like
really if it is fake someone's just like
being really extra to make sure it
sounds real but like you know kingdom
hearts four uh you know they're
definitely making another kingdom ours
that makes sense but one thing that i
didn't notice like when i typed in halo
because there's like a search algorithm
in here
um i didn't see infinite on here
so like maybe it's like this halo
recruit maybe it's like a code name and
when i put in for axis
i didn't see the new game that they just
announced on here
yeah a lot a lot of um it says for
access unannounced so maybe that's it
yeah a lot of the stuff um from what we
hear is they use a lot of the code names
and another reason why a lot of people
believe shout out to jess courtney he's
got a great article window central a lot
of reasons why a lot of insiders believe
it is because a lot of the code names
that we heard in the real code oh yeah
the actual real code names are like oh
yeah that fable is this and what you
call it you know the typhoons and
avalanches and all this other stuff
i mean maybe there's no need to make a
code name for x column three but that's
in here by name so
uh it's it's interesting like yeah i say
70 30. this list is true and
especially yeah we we know god of war is
definitely coming like there's no way
around that right they they literally
bought a studio what's the studio's name
king nix's
so you know
at the end of the day actually
i hope it's true because of one game
one game out of this whole list there's
obviously kingdom hearts four and
something here but the one that hold man
that final fantasy tactics for you
let that be real
uh i will be okay this whole list could
be fake made up that's okay just make
sure that final fantasy tactics one is
good oh man
you always gotta worry with square right
because you hear like oh they're
bringing all the old final fantasies
back and then it's not
yeah
says remastered same with chrono cross
is remastered so it's not uh it's not
they're remastered
my hope is that they remake chrono
trigger
even if they bring back it's just final
fantasy tactics as remastered i'm okay
with that yeah because uh guess what i
was i accepted the reality that there
would be no remaster or remake or
anything right so the fact that i get a
remake is a remaster that'd be good for
me no doubt but i hope the list is true
because there's a lot of nice games on
here man like i hope the list is true no
doubt solve the list the video the
g-force you believe in it well yeah yeah
man i think it's mostly true i mean you
had a couple like microsoft stepped out
and was like no halo 5 is not coming to
pc or whatever but and that's just
probably because it's not worth the work
like it's not gonna you know yeah i
think if i'm coming to pc it already
came by now yeah it's not happening so
you know certain things i'm sure we just
you know code names and certain things
i'm sure we're sort of speculative and
like
we assume this is coming but yeah man
like all the the sony stuff
it it is what it is and i'm glad it's
happening
it is what it is
hey
that demon souls on a pc is going to
look real nice like god of war and a
piece it's going to look real nice you
know i'm not going to even play god of
war on pc but a dude might pick it up to
show support
i've done that with every sony game so
there you go yeah not play them but
and then when it comes to the microsoft
stuff obviously you knew that was
happening um
the thing about that is is is
it's gonna be hand in hand with like the
microsoft store stuff and and steam
obviously they're working towards that
being the case where you don't have that
sort of exclusivity period microsoft
store whatever all the weirdness that we
have with uwp and
inferior versions being on the microsoft
store so that that stuff is all yeah
that's happening um the square enix
stuff like attic said all those
remasters of tactics and corner cross
i'm excited for but it's real i believe
the vast majority of it because
everything is fluid now we don't have
that situation like we had in the ps3
days where the cell processor is so
removed from what everything everybody
else is doing that
you just can't get those games in
fluidly across all platforms like it
just wouldn't work well we're at that
point where they they are they're all
essentially pcs yes yeah pretty much
i'm happy with this i hope a lot of this
is like tekken 8 oh titanfall titanfall
3 oh my god
oh my god
i did see someone put in the chat and
that this makes me like kind of
skeptical about it but that final
fantasy 9 remake like
[Music]
maybe score enix realized that like they
got that hit from the marvel like you
know literally hit like they got hit
they didn't generate a hit they got hit
so
maybe you know they're like look like
the people like the remakes so like like
let's double down on the remakes that's
having a final fantasy 7 remake and nine
being at the same time like
no i mean i'll jump in you know yeah i
think look i think a lot of this stuff
is real i agree with y'all i think the
uh the codings that are being used kind
of fall right in line
with what the rumors were what these
early projects were i i would king i do
feel the pc ports are kind of hilarious
because um you know a lot of people in
the playstation community fought that
for a long time which i don't understand
why it's not a big deal like king said
it's not affecting you you know this is
sony
making big you know smart business moves
to try to get it on other platforms so
seeing god award pc when people were so
bad when we had randon and you know some
other people on that we we we said that
this is going to happen no they'll never
do it it devalues their thing and we
heard it you know now all of a sudden
you know what the new thing is now king
well now
even though it was never going to happen
now it's but it's two three years okay
whatever whatever whatever it helps to
make you sleep at night but at the end
of the day it's happening this is a
business that sony's in the business of
making money in my opinion you want them
to exist to be around to be more
successful so yeah god of war makes
sense all this other stuff makes sense
they just need to bring that stuff to
game pass
i know okay and then you can look at it
from the aspect like you know who says
that them not putting stuff on pc
you know it's gonna have a domino effect
where you're having you know not maybe
not the next god of war but the the god
of war after that where they have the
double the budget because they had the
playstation revenue and the pc you want
the games that you like to be supported
so if you're doing well they're getting
some money on the back end salute you
know to me that the biggest thing that
excited me shout out to um again just
caught in windows central great article
you know talking about this stuff he
actually talked about some other project
names that were kano in this list that
really excited me one was called um
project cobalt you know in exile and
exile i didn't know about this so they
got yeah i didn't either yeah wasteland
studio they're making a new fps rpg
so i'm super excited about that because
i think nxl is super underrated you know
wasteland did well and then with a
budget with a big scale i think he
talked about shout out to the xbox too i
looked at them they talked about some
stuff that they saw on art station kind
of like steam punk-ish vibes looks
really cool so i'm hyped about that they
got other um xbox game publishing deals
as well i think there's another one
called in this
they've got stuff coming so to me this
list is accurate because in a covid
world with a pandemic
geforce now makes sense as to for
development tools and people utilizing
stuff in remote locations you know what
i'm saying so you know i don't know who
left the
you know the laptop door open you know
how the links used to be they like
somebody never leave a laptop in a bar
yeah
look at it from this standpoint like i
know a lot of people like oh how could
this possibly leak
um the the people who do e3 what's their
the tsa or know that yes esa yeah the
esa like they leaked
mad
info like sometimes it just happened
like there ain't nothing you could do
about it like yeah i i do believe like
yeah percentage super strong this
stuff's happening and some of the stuff
that they're working on is pretty
exciting i think too notice they didn't
deny it
yeah
yeah they tried to fake you know the the
corporate statement we you know why
would you say anything at that point
exactly what they put out makes it seem
more real it's just like just don't say
anything yeah jimmy they said
placeholders we got placeholders
speculative we're not this doesn't
confirm anything exactly okay yeah okay
all right whatever whatever whatever
they need to make to sleep at night now
every e3 people are gonna pull from this
list what are your things gonna get
announced here i just thought like i
said the king's boy i thought it was
funny because i know
you know me and him has been on that the
pc stuff that something's gonna happen
yeah one of the comments said uh jesse
spud they said the evil within three was
on there yeah that yeah that was where i
was like oh this is fake because i
didn't think they would go back to that
well but i i'm glad they will because
that's underrated underrated second
second one no doubt so that's all i got
oh let's get this paul get up out of
here and then we'll get swimming chats
afterwards um nua people with the rumors
swirling of potential major xbox
acquisition happening soon which of
these entities do you want microsoft to
pursue
a take too interactive
b warner brothers
c
sega
or d i don't care but if none of these
acquisitions happens the xbox insider
community about to get this work salute
to everybody in the chat the legendary
jimmy champagne rocked with us the
entire way the lord of horror the lord
of halloween tremendous gaming history
ps ready and hopefully xbox ready soon
my man where can the five people find
you what you got going on sir you can
find me everywhere at jimmy champagne
and if you look on twitter all my
stuff's linked uh yeah good tease on
xbox already that is coming soon we're
sorry we're starting it up
it's all good
uh yeah yeah
it's not for me it's like i'm behind the
scenes but uh no doubt yeah uh yeah look
look me up jimmy champagne you wanna see
my halloween stuff that's on my main
channel you want to see my playstation
stuff that's on ps ready guys thanks a
lot this is so much fun this is like one
of the best podcasts i've ever been on
like this is great
i'm putting his twitter in the chat guys
thank you brother i really appreciate
you you know far past the other laws you
know absolute pleasure meeting you you
know obviously at the last stand media
event and just so down the earth really
cool and i know solve love talking hard
with you
yeah man just i just like your journey i
like what you're doing out there
continue to great works and one thing i
realize about you that i really
appreciate you like i said the
analytical nature how humble you are how
willing you are to help other content
creators that's very rare because
usually a lot of people in this space
you know sadly they want to deal with
people that's only on a level and all
this
politic garbage and i hate that yeah i
mean that's one thing i hate so much i
hate it bro and one thing about you
jimmy we was kicking it was in the ball
we had our drinks we was chilling
everybody yeah good time good vlogs
can't wait to hang out again so salute
the legendary jimmy champagne lord attic
we're gonna find people find you what
you got going on sir
follow me on twitter lord
thanks for telling me on uh
youtube it gave me addict i'll have my
first video in a while up tomorrow uh
you can also find me streaming at uh uh
i don't know if i'm gonna stream on the
iop twitch or my actual personal twitch
i don't know yet uh but you can find me
over there uh you know i streamed a lot
of death loop you know first i want to
thank jimmy for coming on here you know
it's like cog said like
a lot of gatekeeping going on in this
industry like a crazy amount of
gatekeeping like it might as well be the
great wall of china yes
it's just like what's your somehow
addict i can't talk to you and it's just
it's just frustrating because you you'll
meet people at events and like yeah man
what
like you you tell good chemistry you
feel like you know this is going
somewhere and then you know it's six
seven months go by you know yo you said
you wanted to come on he's like we got a
room for you and crickets they never
respond they they don't join
and to me me and cogs always been that
kind of person it's like look if you
don't if you got if you're busy just
thinking
you know because oh yeah that makes it
so much easier yeah
because there's nothing worse in this
industry than feeling like you know cool
i met some cool people
and then it turns out they're not cool
people they they were just putting on a
game
at the event yeah i mean that
unfortunately has happened more often
than not
with me
just like for
all that [ __ ]
oh sorry
for every one big guest we've had on
we've had three front on us so you know
uh and you know thanks to to the
viewership you know the the people who
support us every week because you guys
show up in such groves like it's easier
to get people now because they see all
of you they don't got 10 g's but they
get 7 800 live viewership you know like
and people look at stuff like that and
you know they they they gravitate and
they give us a shot you know
shout out to call the moriarty that you
deny
you know we we
went above and beyond making sure
everyone
was able to go on to every show because
you know when it comes to the bigger
guests like we understand sunday's not a
good day for a lot of people
so sometimes we have to move on that and
it's like you know i appreciate everyone
for coming through we had up to like i
think it was almost 5 50 or something
you know definitely love the people that
like the podcast love the people that
super chatted you know and we got some
surprises for you guys in the future man
we got some surprises no doubt lord
solve where can the five people find you
what you got going on sir yeah man first
off big shout out to jimmy man it was a
pleasure meeting you at the last stand
media event um immediately just hit it
off obviously because the horror man
love horror in in every in every way
shape or form whether it's like it's
movies or gaming and we we just hit it
off um but i want to thank you for again
for being that type of person that's
just
you know we got into conversations about
the business behind like youtube and
stuff like that yeah yeah like with you
and dustin as well dustin was standing
behind me with a with a stoke like you
know
talking boss stuff that boss thomas yeah
man but you guys really that's what's in
this element yes he's never looked
really wise
but it's just so cool that you guys are
there like willing to sit there and talk
to the old man in the room and show them
how it's done because again it's so much
it's funny there were certain things
that you talked about when we were
talking and literally the following week
i saw people implementing those exact
things that had never done it before i'm
like wait a minute what the hell and
it's like you guys are so i mean i don't
know if you've spoken to these
particular people i'm talking to but if
not it's just the fact that you guys are
so on the you have your finger on the
pulse of how this stuff works and how to
be successful and the fact that you're
just so willing to share that is amazing
bro so i wish you all the best all the
success man i can't wait to have you on
again i love to hang out again
absolutely a lot of people
they don't want to give that kind of
info because they're they're in the back
of their mind they're scared what they
show me up you know what i'm saying like
they don't want to get that kind of
yeah you know what a lot of people know
what to do they just don't want to
because
they're like oh i'm obsessed with making
art or whatever and it's like you got to
make content for the platform you're on
that's yeah that's
good
the crazy thing is that like we're like
you're like you came up to us you're
like oh my god i love your show guys
whatever oh i was so stoked
i'm like you're jimmy champagne and
we're like yo it was such a moment like
it just goes to show you like you know
we underrated obviously our influence as
well and then obviously we we both share
mutual friends you know obviously shout
out to oh yeah legend you know what i'm
saying
that's yeah you he talks about you guys
all the time
oh man i ever got to be on that show oh
bro we had to do it man i had to cook up
the intro for you but yeah man and like
soft said you know it is very rare and
cool you know to just share that
information with you yeah and help you
know not gatekeep information like
addict was saying right because it's
like you know it's rare man salute to
you for that that was huge we really
took that to heart you have no idea your
your stock went even higher we were
already fair
went through the roof i was like yeah we
got to get jimmy in the problem yeah
i'll tell you right now this is just a
tip
that screen you see on the youtube
studio yeah it literally tells you
everything that i want it's like i want
watch time yeah i want click-through
rate yes and that's all it is like
it's all right there they're telling you
nothing crazy lord king we're going to
find people find you what you got going
on sir
first i'd like to apologize to jimmy for
being tardy
oh no i'm talking again no no jimmy i'm
never late and the fact that i was late
i do apologize you didn't get the full
king experience so you do need to come
back five five minutes shy yeah don't
worry i got you
but he's mad you didn't get the music
intro
i got hyped up for the music yeah yeah
yeah i i do apologize but to to have
somebody that reads fran gore magazine
and and stuff like that who is uh
steeped in horror uh that can appreciate
the genre to look at maternal and pull
off some movie references to it to get
more intrigued by it
i think that's special and and i think
that's needed you know understand um
yeah i appreciate it a lot and making
movies and just living your truth is
really fun and they they got a chance to
meet you i wish i would have got a
chance to meet you because you sound
like a cool dude and i do watch uh you
know a lot of stuff so i do see your
stuff and you are on my timeline sir
and i do appreciate your content thank
you for showing up um kos yes sir he's
going up this week uh again i'm having a
tough time doing this kos because it's
uh talking about uh my fallen comrade uh
chris
oh um
he's uh x-men dude so you see cable in
the back you can see him in a different
position
right now so i did all the other stuff
the static shots and and i did uh
distill stuff it's just i'm having a
hard time getting through the actual
video talking about them
that'll be up next week please go to
lords of gaming.net where we have a ton
of writers a ton of stuff up there
please check that out please watch lord
cognito with andy bontis and ty guy
travis
with the last word uh destiny uh i would
flow with guys so um right now i'm in
trials running around like a new kid
shout out
there man shout out travis hit me up
travis yeah they can't handle me son
it's crazy but uh see you guys next week
oh um lords uh uh legion of doom yes
fridays 9 p.m oh 9 p.m please check it
out uh we had the sick one on this week
uh check us out next week uh it's uh the
content is a little blue okay oh oh okay
[Music]
and yeah i can say though if people
aren't aware jimmy kid statue
uh collecting in the community is pretty
amazing for anyone who's into that and
comic book culture highly advised you
know what i'm saying they should do
they've been putting it down for a
minute now it's the rebrand so more even
more goodness so check that out yeah i
was looking at that cable statue i was
like that that is cool that is cool
thank you yes
you already know that's all i got so we
got these super chats to read but i
don't want to keep jimmy hostage while
we pay the bills to get out of here oh
let's finally you can go through that
cool question
yeah no doubt no doubt so um solving
want to get that these are i said
yeah give me one second it's not too
many um
bingham five dollar super chat microsoft
could always go full thanos like an end
game and pull out these awesome studios
and i p from third party publishers like
the mine stone from vision
thank you
oh my god jesus
then we have clutch man two dollars
which a calvin and hobbes game by double
fine would be sick yeah
yeah that's actually cool
and we have raiden blade five pounds
super chat just arrived looks like i'm
late to the show so king what if series
i love them so what you think about what
if spider-man versus hulk
it's king are you talking about the
actual books
well i guess he he i guess he's coming
off of watching the series okay i don't
know they actually have really books
where they fought already so it's not a
real what if um i thought the last
episode of what if was the best one out
of the box
i thought they uh explored
different avenues of stuff that we they
had to build the universe to get to this
point this episode if iron man one isn't
made and black panther isn't made we
don't get this episode so this episode
was a real peek inside of what they can
actually do with the properties that
they do have and um i love the last one
the zombies episode a good take on it it
was this it's been a very good series
cool cool cool what else you guys saw
then we got michael askew junior five
dollars if you chat without insomniac
and naughty dog would sony have the
market share that they have i feel so
many fans are really studio fans okay
well without one arm and the other arm
would you
be able to swim in the pool is this
making sense
hilarious
yeah we have a raid and blade
for microsoft xbox to buy a japanese
company it would be tango game studios
to purchase because they are
japanese-based companies
sub-subsidiary comes to mind uh they own
them already
oh newsflash they brought them yeah
and
then we have one bad mother
five dollars in the chat monthly psa ilp
continues to be gaming's most
entertaining podcast has been for years
tell your friends thank you bro man
salute to him salute the xbox era i was
rocking with those guys four hours but
oh it was amazing yeah it saluted them
yeah tremendous and he does tremendous
work with those guys he's a writer for
their site xbox ever salute those guys
we're gonna do something special with a
special nick and uh like uh sick and of
course woeful we gotta get them get them
on you know we had one bad mother on obm
salute him no doubt we got everything
raiden blade two pound super check i was
talking about the book so he's really
into the to the books as opposed to the
show
they they they don't they actually have
fought so
yeah so so it wasn't a what-if
for john romita junior actually does a
great take on uh spiderman versus the
hulk nice no doubt all caught up yes sir
all right cool look everybody thank
y'all for coming this was amazing
legendary jimmy champagne in the
building
yes sir and we will be back next week
some more fun lot of things cooking up
everybody enjoy your sunday that's all i
got to get anything else before we got a
roll up out
be good all right everybody y'all enjoy
your sunday we out
[Music]
hidden blade well we forgot what we
forgot he just added at the end oh okay
what do you say
we laugh yeah raiden blade five pound
super chat i'm already aware that they
own them i'm saying it's easy it's an
easy way into japan okay
okay
apologies
peace
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
you